Do you stream with your which are
problems ladies and gentlemen,
I present to you the lovely and talented
Mr Sam triply Santra.
Gentlemen,
privilege man.
Thanks for having me here.
Do I do love how you're wearing
sunglasses inside?
I'm going to do it for you.
You don't have this slight shift.
Black people only be able to do it.
I want to rock that.
Yeah.
Why?
Why can they do it?
So you're broadcasting right now,
right?
Aren't we?
So as we're broadcasting does not show
up on ustream.
Yeah,
for me,
I don't dare you.
Let's try it again.
Might be a little slow today.
Ustream,
is it blogging?
We have a problem.
There we go.
Good.
Okay.
Yep,
we're good.
Okay.
So it was a,
it was a total false alarm.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have sunglasses on.
Why?
Because Sam triple,
he showed up with sunglasses and the
adult respect.
I'm going to follow suit.
Let's do it.
I've never done a show with sunglasses
on.
Let's do it well.
So what is it about black?
Oh,
before we even get started and we knew I
needed to get a new one at these
flashlights.
By the way,
Joe.
Uh,
I think I'm using my fucking the shit
out of yours.
I don't know if I'm not cleaning it well
enough.
This is the one I fucked.
So you don't want to touch this one.
We really fucked.
That doesn't feel real.
I think it's a computer technology to
really fuck that.
Fuck the Shit Outta my cat.
Wants to get out man.
But I let my cat out too.
While you were up.
There's too many people in there.
She's freaking out here.
That's how we roll.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Some people that work out of a
professional studio in Hollywood.
Me,
I got computers that are always on.
I got a cat that wants to get out of my
office.
She does too.
Girl.
Don't insult their brother.
That's before we get started.
Doctor fucked one of these.
I'll get to know a bunch of dogs.
You ever on these dude?
It's,
of course you'd beat off.
We all do.
When you know dies with functional army
and,
and Dick's attached.
We all beat off and this is way better
than beating.
Really?
Yes,
it's way better.
We are actually sponsored by them,
but even if I wasn't sponsored by them,
I would tell you to fuck this thing.
Are you telling me that they're better
enough?
My hand way better,
way better because your hand,
you always this,
you're getting,
oh,
you're still getting like a signal from
your Dick,
but your hand signal from your hand that
you're holding a dick.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like you're doing it to yourself
and even though you know exactly what
you like,
you know you're not gonna.
Get the same feeling as if someone else
was doing it to you or if you're
actually fucking something that's
amazing.
This is the next best thing to having
sex.
I'm telling you,
dude,
it's the best masturbation device for
the male ever created.
It feels like you're fucking law upkeep
though,
Dude.
You squirt some lube in it.
You fuck it.
You shoot your load,
you uncork the bottom.
This disgusting Snot ball of shame comes
out like the spit valve and the trumpet.
Dump your load out.
Then you stick this in the faucet,
clean the fucking shit so you don't
pull.
Don't pull the fish out of the bucket at
all.
You can.
I do.
I pull the fish out of the bucket anyway
with Brian logins or Japanese Americans
got dammit where I'm like,
yeah,
but by the way,
what Brian means by pull the fish out of
the bucket.
This is what Brian means.
This is his patented move.
He says that this.
She just hooked that up to the back of
your faucet,
or are you good?
It's a very controversial thing.
This flashlight.
It's a very controversial subject.
Sex Toys and I don't think it should be.
I think fucking dumb.
It's a biological maintenance thing,
you know?
That's what masturbation,
as you know,
people think about it somehow or
another,
still like for something dirty to it
like that.
This,
you know,
rubber thing that you stick your Dick in
because somehow or another this would be
bad.
You know,
what sucks about that is when you have
your married friends over for a nice
drink or two and it's laying around and
you accidentally leave it in the
bathroom and not only do you leave it in
the bathroom with like with the lid
open,
so it's just this pussy while he's
taking a Piss,
there was like a pubic hair on it of
course.
And he came out and didn't say a word
and then I went to the bathroom a couple
minutes later.
I'm like,
oh,
he didn't even say anything,
you know,
like going to like keep it to himself.
Like don't maybe just assumes you're
afraid.
Maybe hit it,
but it wouldn't tell you about him being
married though.
Huh?
What?
You know,
because he was just like,
you know,
he's not,
he's not.
He's not like fucking fake pussies.
Are you wearing sunglasses?
Those are glasses.
No glasses.
I've been using the Internet too much
lately,
so my eyes are fucking killing me.
Dude.
You're cooking your eyes.
Did last three days.
I've done nothing but surf.
The Internet on balls are getting.
Not,
they're not bad.
I can still read,
but they're not as good that I can
definitely see a deterioration,
but I'm just assuming that's a part of
the aging process.
I've been on youtube constantly watching
pro wrestling,
nonstop food,
Hulk Hogan versus the ultimate warrior.
I was like,
I watched that.
I was getting really.
You watch just because I got this right.
Let's talk about that before we even say
anything more.
Sam.
He has a fantastic show tomorrow night
at the Hollywood improv.
If you've never seen the Sam triply
naughty show.
It's not just stand up comics where he
gets a bunch of,
you know,
really the best comics are buddies from
La will go up and perform.
I've done a show after the show last
month,
right?
Yeah.
He was murdered a Heckler,
so it was so much fun.
It's such a fun what it is though.
It's not just stand up comedy,
stand up comedy,
but it's a variety.
He's got like a variety show going on.
He has like a little game shows going
on.
It shows video porn stars.
That's the main thing they get this
week.
You have Dana,
don't you have Dana d ironman and Joanne
Angel.
That's great,
and he does this show.
It's like a comedy variety show.
Porno stars.
They do question and answer and Trivia
type shit.
It's really fucking hilarious stuff and
it's a fun evening.
It's not just like a comedy show,
which I love comedy,
but I liked that you're mixing it up.
You got comedy,
you've got a bunch of variety.
It really feels like a vegas show and
that's what I said when when I first saw
it,
I was,
you know,
someone should recognize that and put
this fucking thing in Vegas because I
know you've put a lot of time and effort
into it.
It's really a fun show to watch.
Yeah,
I look forward to that.
My favorite part of the show is telling
clean comic.
Say,
can't do it.
I'm sorry you were cleaned.
Can't use just like porn.
You what you're doing,
man.
It's,
it's.
You're creating this really fun party
atmosphere.
You know,
that's what your show is.
It's not just a comedy show.
It's like a comedy show,
but all this stuff that's happened,
it's all fun and silly and it's like a
great move.
If you want to get a check.
Horny,
right.
Your show is all about fucking.
Your standup is about fucking.
The show's all about fucking your porn
stars up.
Everybody's having a great time.
So by the end of the night,
if you're the girl you brought,
if you,
you know,
if you picked her correctly when you're
bringing it to the show,
she's going associate having fun with
fucking.
She had fun with you.
I just want to throw them Pavlov's shit.
Some type shit son.
I'm saying that's actually my.
My crowd is more of a large part is
women.
Yeah.
Oh,
there was a lot of chicks when we were
there.
Yeah.
You have a lot of women that come.
It's because it's fun,
man.
It's a fun show and again,
girls I think really loved those like
weekly,
monthly type shows.
You remember when before I'm a steel
panther became big.
Weren't they a metal shop?
Is it the same band?
I don't know if it's the same band or
not because I just got into them when
you showed me and we went to Vegas.
Dude,
how much fucking fun was that?
No,
it was awesome.
It's more than just a music show.
It's like,
it's like when Steel Panther,
they do like,
uh,
it's,
you know,
it's like,
it really rekindled these eighties bands
that dude does like the best fucking
Ozzie impression that and the really
good musicians,
you know.
So the music is tight,
you know,
it's good man.
We're just saying we saw him in Vegas at
the House of Blues.
We're going to see him again because I
think they're on after me on July
second.
I think they're playing the second and
the third.
I'm not,
I'm not sure,
but I think they are.
Um,
but they,
they were on after it.
Was that,
that or was it after the UFC was the
next day?
I don't know.
I can't remember the next day.
It was after the UFC.
So we came down and we watched it.
I think it was a pretty late show,
but it's fucking awesome.
It was metal.
Copper,
a steel panther ruined one of my
favorite gigs in a pub.
There was this place called moon doggies
and every time I did it I always got
legs like weird,
weird lays too,
like it was awesome.
And then Steel Panther,
one of them,
they started doing it on the same night
and then went away.
But dude,
I mean we're chicks chicks who blue cows
and stuff like that and like I'm like,
that's a female ad blue an animal.
That's all I know.
And I'm like,
check a balloon animal.
Really?
Would you like for a video?
Just for fun.
She balloon animal for fun.
How do you,
how'd you find out about this?
She told me.
Wow.
That doesn't mean you don't really feel
like you scored with that.
That girl's willing to suck our cows.
Dick.
Yeah,
but she's willing to do that.
What?
What will she let me do?
She'll let you do what you did.
You pretty much have full game on that.
Yeah,
but you don't feel like you accomplished
anything.
You feel like,
wow,
this is the lowest hanging fruit ever
right now.
Let's check flux animals.
They can even talk,
you'll start thinking about it and like
Lysol on your Dick and this is,
isn't there a certain thing like that,
like,
you know,
when I talk about in my act about child
molesters that you have to kill him
because you can't really bounce back
from that.
Yeah.
It's a very funny joke.
When we think about that with,
with chicks,
there's a certain amount of things that
a chick can't do,
you know,
in her past where you can just accept
that she grew from that and moved on.
You know,
like,
like the conversation comes up about
like would you be able to date a porn
star or would you be able to date a
prostitute?
Oh,
that would be the craziest one.
Right?
What if there was a girl who is a high
end prostitute and she felt really bad
about it,
but she did it for like a year and then
she quit,
but she was the most awesome chick you
ever met.
The back of your head is going to be
gone,
but shit.
I mean,
I know I fucked up.
I've made mistakes.
I'm no fucking perfect person,
but God damn you were a hooker.
Fuck.
You know,
it's like you would have to be
incredibly open minded to like watching
their girl get bone.
But the problem with that,
those guys are all fucked up,
man.
Those guys are just as fucked up.
They're the type of people that don't
take it in the ass if given the
opportunity.
One of those,
I don't want to say that they're fucked
up.
They could just be crazy swingers.
But with the people that are fucked up
or the cuckold guys,
the guys who like want guys to fuck the
girl in front of the uh.
Yeah.
And like,
and like embarrass them and like,
do you,
have you ever met one of these people or
do you think that was just involved in
Orange County?
Like guys who pay like large black guys.
I saw a picture online,
I dunno,
maybe Stan hope send it to me.
Somebody sent it to me.
Somebody fucked up,
send it to me and it's a this fucking
guy and this girl together and the man
is sucking this guy's Dick in front of
the girl.
The black eyes making this man suck his
dick and then he's gonna fuck the white
girl and he's wearing a suit and it's
one of the most disturbing pictures.
It's just something so primal and
disturbing.
That's a broken dude.
Any dude who like wants to suck his dick
and then once the girl to once he's not
even get.
He wants to be humiliated by this guy.
He wants to fuck his girl in front of
them.
Then they.
A lot of times they come in the guy's
mouth.
Can you imagine?
How much does that guy own you?
He fucked your wife and then came in
your mouth.
Oh my God.
You know,
if you found out a chick used to do
that,
you know what I'm saying?
Well,
I dated this guy.
He was crazy.
He used to have black guys come over and
fuck me in front of him and he would
suck the black guy's Dick.
I was so uncomfortable.
I really wasn't into it,
but he was into it,
so we kept doing it and caught.
I'm so glad I got over that.
You'd be like,
what the fuck happened?
Wait a minute,
didn't to remember with the white guy
sucked the black guys deck.
Then the black guy fucked you and then
the black guy came in the white guy's
mouth check please.
Right?
We snowballed 20 times back and forth
and seeing too much hooker.
Too much.
My dear.
You've got too much life experience.
I cannot handle that.
That's where I tap it.
But isn't there something about like
having your getting your check to do
filthy shit that's like,
it's almost like a point,
but then you kind of go,
this is a girl and this girl,
this girl I love.
Why am I making her do it?
What's even worse is when he wants you
to do a tour,
they want to be humiliated.
You hear about girls like that want to
be hit.
I want to be choking.
Thing is what gets me.
I dated a chick.
I want to get.
It was uncomfortable.
Scary.
You don't want associate rape with
sexuality,
with you know,
with.
I mean,
you know,
the girl obviously knows she can trust
you.
The girl.
I mean chicks are into it.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not saying you shouldn't do it.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
I think as a man though,
the last thing you want to do is
associate like aggressive violence with
sexuality.
I don't want to connect those two in my
head because I know people get connected
with things.
You know,
you get like fetishes come from like,
I used to have a foot fetish because I
dated this girl who was really her feet.
Yeah.
She was really into her feet and she had
like,
you know,
cute feet.
She just was really into him though and
she will like rub her feet on my deck
and shit like that.
Crazy.
But you know,
and she would try to,
to like a jerk me off of her feet.
She was afraid.
I just met somebody that like that.
She was a freak.
But this was when I was really young.
I was like 16,
17 and I was like one of my first
girlfriends.
So I had this foot thing for awhile.
You know,
you connect,
you connect that with sexuality.
I think it's weird.
You get into connect.
Yeah,
maybe that's weird,
but it wasn't like I was only in feet,
like I just thought I liked girls were
pretty feet.
But you didn't see her feet and then
like Papa Boehner did you?
No,
no,
but I thought I've found them attractive
to found the whole package attractive
and the fact that she was really into
it.
So you don't have a foot fetish now?
No,
I don't like them to be gross,
but no,
I don't have a foot fetish.
You take care of your feet,
see my nails,
but it's just so it doesn't scratch
people and you just never get your feet
done or anything like that.
The Fuck Outta here.
Sunday said,
look what you're looking at.
What are you taking?
Anybody to be fucking cleaning my toe.
No,
but once you have a job I ever had.
Have you ever had it done there?
No,
I don't want to do it once I said the
same shit.
What's so special about getting your
nail Polish feels good and it feels
clean and once you're done you're just
like,
wow,
I feel like this has been a feet.
You Lazy.
Fuck,
wash washcloth and stuff,
so it's like you're wiping.
They brought me the one to get my feet
down.
One time I swear to God,
I walked in the all the Asian ladies
look at me and then they run to the back
of the room behind this door and you can
just hear them arguing and then wants to
do.
Nobody wants Armenian walk through and
they're like,
that's a long day.
I saw one of those old guys at starbucks
the other day that had like the sandals,
but his toenails were all super yellow
and like huge,
like curling up and then he had like all
those like scabby things all over his
feet.
Like it was like drying skin and stuff.
Trim mine mostly out of courtesy for
guys that Jujitsu.
Right.
Because it sounds gross but.
And Gay too.
But you scratched us with your toenails
and Jujitsu all the time.
I got scratched by fingernails and
toenails,
so I always keep my shit really,
really,
really short.
But there's guys that don't.
Man.
Sometimes you're rolling with God.
You looked down at their feet and like
the wolf man right now and they're
scrambles and in scrambles.
People push and they push off their feet
and they can claw you up,
man.
What their toenails.
Now we're going to try to get your back
and they're trying to get those hooks in
there,
trying to dig the hooks to get butterfly
hooks on you.
They could fuck you up with their toes,
man.
They can cut your shit up.
Is that why you haven't heard from all
the scratch marks on your face?
Joe On furry son.
I'm trying to suck on this beard son Yo.
But going back to what you're talking
about is a bit weird fetishes.
Don't you think that people should just
embrace what they are and trying to
find.
All was saying too that I was saying,
me personally,
I don't think.
I mean this is just an opinion.
I don't think it's good to connect
violence and sex.
You know,
I connected feet with sex for awhile
because of this freaky girl that had did
it.
That's another wrong with that.
No one's getting hurt.
If you connect violence when sex and
then you get with somebody that you'd
like and maybe she isn't into that shit,
you know,
maybe.
I mean,
let's be honest,
the violent sexual relationships really
don't have a lot of fucking shelf life.
She gotta assume you're going to have
another girlfriend after this one that
wants you to choke her and brutalize
macro in the head.
How long are you going to stay with her?
Right.
You know,
we're going to have kids and then like
involve them into the whole man.
Obviously
people adapt and change and evolve.
But it's just,
there's something about that.
There's something about violence like
attacking and sex.
There's one thing about fucking someone
hard,
but it's another thing about,
you know,
when it,
when it becomes some sort of like a sort
of a rape thing,
like a rape fantasy,
some weird shit about rape fantasies.
That is weird.
But you know,
it's like I do a joke about that Auto
Rocca fixation.
It's like my,
you know,
my whole thing is get a spotter.
You know what I'm saying?
Like get a buddy.
No.
Sit there when you hang yourself.
And you're whacking it and when your
eyes roll,
they lift you up for that.
Do you know what I'm saying?
But because they're so scared of putting
it out there that they,
they hide hustling,
you know?
It would be a very good point.
You mean look,
think about all the shit
priest do.
Right?
And,
and somehow,
you know,
forgive themselves for it or justify it.
There was that one priest that Baptist
minister,
very famous guy,
obviously they're not the same as
priests,
but who he died with a black dildo up
his ass in a wet suit hanging because he
did the auto erotic association thing.
Just think of all the shit that that
guy's willing to justify,
you know,
if you.
I mean,
not really.
That's actually a bad example because I
said he was a bishop,
but hopefully they'll catch a priest
doing the exact same thing and this will
make sense.
But this poor guy couldn't just tell
people,
hey,
I got this crazy thing I like to do.
Man,
that's really fucked up.
I'm in the weird.
I don't want you to see it,
but I'm afraid I'm gonna die.
Yeah.
So coming to watch me beat up,
just sit there and spot it should be an
iphone app where you like,
you hit start and if you don't like put
in a code in like three minutes or
something like that.
It caused nine slash 11 automatically so
you can choke yourself or whack off on
what is it about people that just trip
certain things
like that.
Like you know,
like they'll get into just whatever
weird fetish at tying people up and
gagging.
Um,
and you remember our pal that used to
like to beat his check and she still
liked to get whipped.
Remember that he used to whip her.
Who?
Mr D dot.
Do you remember that?
You don't remember that?
We can't.
We can't say who because he dated
someone famous.
All right,
we'll talk later.
We'll talk off.
There were no snitches.
Folks.
Snitches get stitches.
I gave it to them and cold.
He don't even know who the fuck I'm
talking about.
I'm confused,
right?
We'll forget about it.
But what's head dance?
Just let's just try to figure out what
the fuck it is.
I mean,
I know that my thing with feet was
because I dated a girl is freaky with
her feet.
I have a boob thing.
Definitely,
you know,
every guy is gonna know.
But,
but like,
like I always joke older girls were the
vagina's.
That's what I'm doing.
I,
I get blinded by headlights like
nonstop.
Hey,
I found that we all do.
I know,
but that's what I'm saying.
Basic Man on the face and ass man.
You know,
there's two totally different things
when it comes to,
uh,
with breast sexuality,
what would make some sexual.
There's natural tits where you have
conflict is a natural natural draw,
but it's just purely sexual.
But there's a different draw with fake
tits,
with fake tits.
There's still a draw and you feel stupid
for being drawn to these stupid things
because you know that they're really
just bags of water underneath the skin
and it's not the same draw from real
tits.
But there's something,
a little extra dirty about the fake,
a little extra turn you on a bit because
you know this,
she's the,
she wants so bad.
She was like,
I want to make sure,
you know,
I really like that you're right.
And they could say that it's like that.
They're just trying to look attractive
and all that good.
But what does that mean?
You want to look like somebody wants to
fuck you.
You want people to really want to fuck
you.
I would agree.
Unless it's one of those like,
no,
I just got to be because of their really
droopy,
you know?
But for the most part,
yeah,
I will.
Look,
there's nothing wrong with getting
breast implants if you want to do it
wrong.
Don't get me wrong.
If I was a girl,
I'd probably have,
um,
if I had a small boobs,
I'll get a boob job.
Fuck it.
Why not?
How about breastfeeding?
I think that's when girls is give up
because it hurts too much because that's
the only thing I can think of.
I did a girl a long time ago.
She had,
she was just born with giant ones.
She had a breast reduction before I met
her.
She was so happy though because for her,
like her back used to fucking killer.
She had these giant ease,
a natural ease.
Wow.
I actually have a family member I've
been in.
I've said that novela was right.
I have a friend that,
uh,
she's born with a gigantic cod.
Is Bruce breast or lightest or whatever
it's called.
Where is your breast?
Just art.
Retardedly.
They're retarded bread.
Just a gift from God.
No,
no.
I mean these aren't even real breast.
These look like a fucking a category,
you know,
it looks like a worm or was it like the
old lady breasts where it's like down at
their gut.
And if you look at this person,
you're like,
wow,
that person's fat.
But if you knew it was just like,
hey,
lift the blue up here.
No,
actually I'm fine.
Oh Wow.
They won't let her operate.
She's only like 18 and they won't let
her operate because they'd say you have
to lose 30 pounds because this is a
really serious,
like a procedure,
procedures and the,
I guess you can't be overweight at all.
You have to be really healthy and she
won't do it.
So now this poor girl is just,
wow,
she's so lazy.
She won't lose 30 pounds.
What a lazy bitch.
She know what someone needs to do
something with your microphone.
You're plugging in like how heavy can
you be back in tighter or something?
Everybody's in good shape.
I didn't do anything,
so.
No,
no.
Well Gentlemen,
we got kinks to it wouldn't turn me way
down.
Well,
I'm trying to get rid of that.
That like there's like a buzz in it.
So Rogan,
what the fuck?
Tripling.
I'll tell the story of a you and me and
a heckler.
I don't remember that one.
That was a funny one.
A whenever you want.
I don't know.
It's the greatest heckle kill of all
time.
I was doing a Gig in Phoenix,
Arizona.
Friend of mine at a bar and eat.
Whenever I came in town he'd throw a
standup show.
So I went down to stand up,
uh,
my aunt who's no longer with us,
but she finally got to come see me and
she was like 80 at the time.
So she came down.
My whole family's there.
I'm onstage and I'm doing a joke about
how I got my ass kicked by my
girlfriend.
I got a scar right here from when she
put me in the hospital,
you know,
I got stitches and all that stuff and I
was talking about that and I dropped my
punch and all of a sudden I hear jokes.
I'm like,
what?
She's like,
yeah.
I'm like,
oh,
what do you.
Oh,
who?
And I look and there's this really hot
chick with this huge goon.
She was sitting on his lap and I'm like,
what are you talking about,
lady?
She goes,
that's not your joke.
That's Joe Rogan's joke.
You didn't write that you fucking stole
it from.
I go,
no,
Joe Rogan's my friend.
He doesn't have that joke.
No,
it's his fucking joke.
I just heard him do it.
You're a fucking joke thief.
I go,
well,
how about this?
How about I called Joe and he'll tell
you it's not his job.
She goes,
good,
do it,
but you won't because you're a fucking
joke thief.
I'm like,
I'm on stage,
man.
Please let this have a good ending.
So,
uh,
so I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to call them,
but we got to make a deal.
If he says it's his joke,
I'll quit comedy now if he says it's not
his joke,
you have to come up here and let this
guy in the front row lick your tits.
And she's like,
okay,
but you're not going to make call your
fucking joke thief.
So I called Joe and uh,
usually Joe,
we'll get back to me the next day or
something like that that I'm like,
Oh man,
he's not going to answer the phone.
So I call him.
I leave a message and I'm like,
Joe,
this triply,
dude,
I need you to call me right now.
I'm onstage,
call me and I hang up.
I'm like,
ah,
you didn't answer.
And she's like,
of course he didn't answer because
you're a fucking joke thief.
I go,
it's like Friday night ladies probably
doing sub that all of a sudden my phone
rings act of God.
I don't know what it is.
Awesome.
It's fucking Rogan.
And I'm like,
but then you have a tea and tea and it
drops in the union.
I'm like,
Rogan,
what's up?
He said,
Tripling?
What the fuck are you doing?
I go,
I'm doing stand up.
He goes,
you're on stage right now.
I'm like,
yeah,
I go,
do you do joke about getting your ass
kicked by your girlfriend?
And well,
you know,
Joe,
he doesn't get his ass kicked by
anybody,
so it's not happening.
He's like,
no,
I don't.
I'm like,
okay,
you need to tell this guy this story.
So,
um,
and I tell them that,
you know,
this girl accused me of stealing his
joke,
so I bring this guy on stage.
It's like I might confirm it's Rogan and
then repeat what he says.
Oh,
it's Rogan Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan.
No,
he doesn't do a joke like that.
He's never done a joke like that.
And uh,
Sam Tripoli doesn't have to steal joke
because he's a funny motherfucker.
Fuck you bitch.
And the whole place just goes,
man.
Did you record this?
Do you have a red band?
No,
I think one guy record,
I've always asked them,
it was lost in the ecosphere.
So the whole place goes nuts.
I can't follow that.
So I just am like,
Hey rogen,
thank you so much.
I got to take care of some business.
I hang up,
I go,
okay,
it's time to pay the toll to the troll.
Come up with this guy on your tits.
And she's like,
no,
I ain't going to fucking do it.
And the whole place booze her right now.
So I'm like,
oh,
I can't.
I tried one joke.
I can't follow that.
It's the greatest heck kill of all time.
So I'm like,
okay,
that's great.
Thank you guys so much.
Standing.
Oh,
I'm not lying to you.
Every chick in the place runs up to this
chick and starts fucking laying into
her.
You're a fucking bitch.
You shouldn't have fucking done that.
You made a deal.
You should gun up there.
Let him lick your tits.
Fucking all of a sudden I see this chick
and her goon boyfriend running out of
the bar because they're getting chased
out by checks.
That is awesome.
And I wish you had the club was this.
It was a bark a called.
Oh,
what was the name of the bar?
I can't even remember.
Los Angeles knows in Phoenix.
He was in Hollywood.
I was in Phoenix.
This chick got bitch slapped in the six.
Oh,
two,
three,
three.
That is beautiful.
Isn't it crazy?
You can do that today,
dude.
That's a.
that's one.
A big one.
That would have been such a great
youtube video.
These clubs,
or if they were smart,
they'd be like,
look,
we're always going to record you.
If something fucking crazy happens,
uh,
you know,
we're going to put it on our youtube
page.
We don't,
I don't like hecklers.
I really wish.
Every show is just fun.
Nobody had a good time,
but God damn interacting with those
fucking retards sometimes makes for some
fun shit.
Fuck,
you know.
Have you ever thought about why they
heckle?
Yeah,
I mean,
there's a whole bunch of reasons for
sure.
They're all fucked up in the head.
No one,
no one heckles.
It's a cool person.
It's not what you would do.
I think girls heckled because they're
either attracted to you or they.
They're mad at someone else's.
The center of attention.
There could be that or you could be
offensive to them and they feel like
they have the need to shut you up or
they,
they can stop you.
I've had that.
I've experienced that before where I
felt
like,
uh,
like what I was saying,
like a girl didn't agree with what I was
saying and she just was not going to
hear it.
She couldn't hear it and she had a yell
shit out.
I've had that happen before where they
just,
you could tell they just can't take it.
It's just like they're just too much a
control freak or something.
But you know,
the bottom line is I've seen a lot of
things that I didn't enjoy,
you know,
but I just left,
that's the whole thing.
It's like I hate comment cards.
Nothing wrong with that man.
You know,
you want to know a bunch of people
thought that guy socked,
you know,
if people pay them in cards or just like
mailing lists there.
That's pretty much the club.
Trying to get your information to
advertise for it is boats also to get
feedback.
They read,
they read the feedback.
Then I think there's some good things to
it because of a bunch of people got
turned off to a show,
you know,
they should know.
I mean,
look,
you've got to find your own fucking
audience,
man.
And until people knew what I did,
there was a lot of shows that I did were
a lot of people get offended,
you know,
people that came to see like the fear
factor guy or some guy from television
that they thought was cute and I'm
talking about all kinds of crazy shit
that they don't.
They don't necessarily want to hear
about it,
you know?
So I,
I totally understand the whole feedback
system,
man.
I'm a yelp elite.
I get into the best thing about the
internet is all the criticism that you
get.
It seems to.
It seems like it's not,
but it is because some of it is good.
Some of it is very constructive.
Even if they're douchey about it.
It's like,
think about how you would criticize
something anonymously if you were to
totally anonymous and you weren't a
performer.
You know,
when you saw something like it fucking
sucked donkey text.
This guy blows,
he's got this ridiculous outlook on
life.
It's not well thought out at all.
I don't want to hear him making his dumb
point,
you know,
that's what you'd say if you were
totally anonymous and that's what
they're going to say two,
but guess what,
man,
that's the real reaction to you and it
may be valid and it may not be.
They might be just fucking idiots who
look for negative shit and everything
and they can't look at anything in a
positive way and they could be jealous
and they could have all sorts of other
issues where they don't like other men
having success or anybody having success
because they're unhappy if that's
possible too.
But it's also possible they got some
good points,
man.
You know,
I think it's real hard for us as,
as comedians performance to totally
objective.
Look at your shit.
You know,
sometimes you don't want to.
Sometimes you don't want to edit your
material or edit your writing or you
don't want to like go back on it and
improve it again and improve it again
and try to figure out like,
what's wrong with it?
You know,
sometimes you get lazy,
but people all that shit on Youtube
comments and message boards,
comments,
that's all good for you,
man.
I really believe that that's the best
thing for your psyche to be able to,
to,
to really see things objective.
Lee.
Yeah.
The biggest thing I get on youtube is
that drives me crazy is when people call
me racist,
I just can't stand it because I'm really
not.
I just can't,
can't even read that shit.
Like you can't read anybody on the,
on,
on the Internet because 90 percent of
them are people that.
It might be just somebody you know
fucking with you.
It might just be an interesting.
We've got a friend.
Let me tell this before you go.
We had a friend who broke up with a girl
and she got on every one of his youtube
videos
and would write nasty fucking comments
about them.
She created like a whole profile just to
fuck with them and that's what it is and
it easily or it's just one obsessed
person that's making multiple accounts
to make it seem like there's all these
people flocking to you.
That happens.
A lot of people that think you suck.
I'm saying we know somebody that does
that.
It does happen occasionally,
but I think that's not really worth
looking at.
I think you know,
you look at like,
what's the tone?
What are they saying?
Are they just being retarded?
But is it valid?
There's something to it.
Yeah.
I like it because it doesn't leave it.
I'll leave like he has a valid point.
Made the comment if it's just some
stupid ass,
makes no sense.
Some of you just want attention to.
They just want attention.
They just want to react to that 15 year
olds on the computer.
Then you watch the documentary with
Carlos Mencia.
Dude,
I showed it to you son.
No,
I was saying I haven't seen it yet.
Got to see the uh,
no,
actually I don't care.
I'll tell you exactly what it is on
youtube we heard about this.
They did a documentary called I am comic
and in the comic documentary they talk
to them and see where he just youtube
look for Youtube.
Carlos Mendez he admits to stealing.
He's just so he doesn't admit it,
but he explains what everyone's always
accused him of.
I mean,
he actually,
like,
he actually like Jay tries to justify it
by saying that it's like sampling.
I actually wouldn't care about this at
all.
So after you showed it to me,
it really was amazing.
It was way more than I could ever
imagine he would ever do.
Yeah.
I would have thought that it would have
been some sort of thinly veiled joke or
that,
you know,
he would,
sort of like come up with some sort of a
justification,
you know,
people are jealous or something and,
or just half asset,
but this is like,
you just flat out and that's it,
man.
You just listened to it.
Check,
check this.
Hold on.
Let me turn down all these volume.
You're going to freak out because it's
just so weird.
I was kind of actually starting to feel
really bad for him lately because this
is his twitter has been really
depressing and stuff,
but this,
this is scary.
I felt bad for him after the Marin
podcasts.
Yeah,
well that was hard for him.
I'm sure when Steve Trevino and
Barcelona and all those guys got up,
I start,
I actually sit on my twitter,
you know,
if you ever want to get ice cream,
I'm here for you and I told you,
dude,
he's got a fucking poison your ice
cream.
Like the one guy ruined his life.
Here's the clip.
A lot of people out there.
Why did the interview Carlos,
Carlos,
you can.
We know that listened to me and look at
me when I tell you this with all
honesty,
if you think that I still joke like,
yeah,
you're right.
We're trying to fucking steal jewelry
out of your fucking mind.
When I come to a comedy club,
you better one bitch.
You better get the forecast stage
because if anything even remotely funny,
I'm going to make it mine and Oh,
I'm going to do it.
Shouldn't Mexican in the front.
I'm like a rapper.
Sampled and make it my own.
What does it really my friend,
what it sounds like,
my kind of like somebody else's.
That's almost like watching a man
implode.
There's something about seeing that
because what he's trying to do and make
it look like,
you know,
like he's a bad ass and he doesn't give
a fuck sort of like,
you know,
like I rob people,
like a rapper would say it was the only
thing he could do.
I think he needs to do this.
I think he needs to finally come clean
with it because that's the only way,
unless you want us to live the next 30
years being the joke like,
oh,
watch out for that guy.
You know?
I think he just had to do this.
Trying to justify it.
He's trying to justify it.
I mean he's trying to actually figure
out a way where it could be.
Okay.
Did you notice how he kept saying,
y'all had this amazing memory?
I have this amazing memory,
and then they're like,
well,
when you did this is one time to kind of
go up A.
I can't remember that.
Okay.
Remember that.
You know,
how about the dude doesn't have anything
written down.
How crazy is that as a comic?
Let me tell you something,
man.
There's,
there's a bunch of parts to being a
comic like you,
you know,
this can't stand up.
Comedy is not just your ideas.
It's how you get those ideas out and
that needs honing and you'll take these
ideas.
You'll have an idea for a bit or an idea
for something.
I write everything out.
I write out what I think about
something.
I write out what I think about a subject
just so I know like what my real
thoughts and points are and then once I
do that,
then I start dissecting it.
Okay.
What's funny about this,
when we get to the meat of this,
I know what I feel about this.
No,
let me get to the meat of this.
Now let me get on stage and let me
figure out what's the best way to do
this.
Am I going to introduce this part of the
idea first?
Am I going to go right into the
punchline right away so it's totally
unexpected,
but right to the meat of the,
the joke and then like build onto the
thing once I've already told them what's
happening,
build onto it afterwards and make it
just more ridiculous.
Like how am I gonna approach this?
Like there's a,
there's a lot of craft to it,
man.
You know,
Alibaba,
that invites involves writing shit.
I mean you can sort of remember it,
you know,
I've gone through periods of time where
I had a bunch of bits that they just
sort of came up on stage,
you know,
like they were attached to other bits
and then they branched out,
became bits of their own.
But I never actually wrote them down.
I just knew how to do them from doing a
monster.
And,
but for the most part man,
to create,
to really give something,
some time and some consideration,
you've got to sit in front of a fucking
piece of paper and think you know,
you kinda right.
And if you're doing standup and you're
not writing,
man,
I kinda know.
I kinda think that you're just,
how is it,
how are those even really truly your
opinions?
I mean your opinions are like all
conglomerated with all the people around
you,
but you don't know what the opinion is
until it's you by yourself.
Your act is alive until it's.
Yes.
It's constantly evolving.
Dude.
I always say that.
I always say that it's almost like A.
I mean it's very pretentious sounding,
but I say it's almost like a living,
breathing philosophy,
but I don't want to say philosophy
because that sounds really fucking yoga.
He and pull yourself,
you know,
it's not that it's a philosophy,
but it's the way of looking at life.
It's like this is my way of looking at
this particular situation that's going
on and this particular time and then
once it's recorded it's like frozen and
then it becomes like know part of you
know
who,
who your life was.
You know,
I mean that's.
But that's really what it is.
Right?
So everything I do,
I tried to turn into a joke at some
point.
Do you,
how much time do you spend actually
sitting in front of pieces of paper or
computer writing here?
I do a little different man.
I mean I'll,
I'll sit down and write,
but I feel like I have to flow on stage,
get going.
I'll write it down.
But literally man,
I talked to myself all day.
I just worked a bit worse a bit and like
I'm driving.
I'll be okay here.
This is it.
Okay.
Tag Tag,
tag cut down.
And I don't want to work at too much.
I just want to get on stage one time
getting the natural part,
right?
Yeah.
And then just flow and see where it goes
and just try to talk through it.
And isn't it funny how you got an idea
and you write it out and you think that
you're gonna say it one way,
but then when you're on stage at the
moment just tells you to say it a little
different.
And now little difference.
Pam could make this fucking huge
reaction to just a word.
You can tweak a bit man or a pause or
just to setting it up correctly.
You know,
there's such a craft to it,
man.
It's just something that you're always
fucking with you.
No,
it's so satisfying.
But for a lot of people it's so
stressful.
You know,
I know a lot of dudes that eventually
they want to get out and they want to do
tv shows and shit like that because just
doing the standup all the time,
just relying only on the standup.
It's just such a fucking wild ride,
you know?
Yeah.
They need like Louis C,
k does it,
man.
He does it crazy,
bro.
He does a new special every year and
then throws out all his material and
starts fresh.
That's strong.
It has a strong work ethic right there,
man.
You got to put in some serious work,
you know?
That's uh,
that's,
that's pretty impressive,
man.
That's a dude who's dedicated to comedy.
Do you find yourself always been able to
come up with some mat?
Sometimes I go like a month without
writing anything I like and I'm like,
oh yeah,
so go nuts.
I'm like,
dude,
you know,
what fixes that we'd,
we'd fixes the shit out of that.
You don't smoke weed though?
I'm not.
I quit pretty much drink too.
You should.
If you look at w,
when did you stop drinking again about,
uh,
like two months ago after Canada attempt
to believe through an them towels.
Then what's your addiction right now?
What division do you got going on right
now?
Any.
Well,
I mean like a finger in,
and this is,
this is the way I think you should look
at pot when it comes to comedy.
Po is like a turbo charger for your
imagination.
Ideas that you have normally,
they'll become much more expressive to
go down different alleys.
It's an enhancer for your mind.
People don't appreciate how much of an
enhancer it is because it's associated
with silliness.
It's associated with losers and just
want to sit on the couch and eat
munchies and it's associated with a
bunch of dumb,
Lazy Shit.
But the reality is that the effect of
marijuana is fucking magical.
There's so much to it.
There's so much creatively that happens
to you when you're writing and you get
high.
These ideas just come flowing 300,
400 percent better than when you're
sober and don't recognize can you kind
of treated as an end theologian treated
as something that's helping to enlighten
you,
treat it as something that you're gonna
use as a tool as you just want to get
fucked up and party.
Yeah,
that's the fine line because if you're a
guy who doesn't have the best self
control and that's what most comics are,
most of us are fucking crazy.
The reason why we do comedy in the first
place because we really couldn't do
anything else.
Otherwise we would've done something
else because it beginning.
It's so fucking hard and no one thinks
they're going to make it.
You literally have to have almost no
options and the guys who do have options
tend to go to those options.
Yes,
exactly.
And even if even if you do have those
options span and it's like you,
a comic is going to blow shit off,
there's just no way around that.
Right?
I mean,
just the only way we got to be where
we're at.
You have to be fucking above rapper.
Yeah.
You gotta be at least fucked up.
One starts at like rappers.
I mean those.
They're so hard to wrangle,
bro.
You got to just fuck was my original
thought.
You thought I was smoking weed enhances
everything.
Especially music.
Exactly.
What I think you should do is just,
if you want to try it at all,
if you want to do it at all,
treated as if you're going to go through
and experience.
Don't treat it as if you're going to get
fucked up and party.
That's how I do it.
When I write,
I treated it as if I'm ready to,
I'm going to experience something.
I'm going to go deeper into my mind and
I'll say,
oh,
just get fucked up.
Put them on.
Do some writing,
man.
Now I say,
all right,
I'm getting ready to right here.
I got these ideas.
Now I'm going to,
you know,
get in touch with the spirit world.
Man.
Just thinks of it as a fucking tool to
it.
If it didn't exist,
okay,
and if it wasn't illegal,
it didn't have all these things attached
to it,
you would think that shit is magic.
It makes fucking way better.
It makes food taste better,
it makes you nicer and it makes you way
funnier.
Way more creative.
Way more honest.
Like your shit resonates more when
you're high.
I don't think I can perform high dude.
My head just try.
I think some people are just,
they're wired different because I
understand being to stumbling on stage
because I don't think when I'm.
When I'm stoned I think about something
and I obsess about something and like
ideas and stuff,
but I can't actually like my,
like my okay,
I know what you're saying,
but the reason why you don't think that
going on stage stone would be fun.
It's because going on stage,
it's not a comfortable part of your
everyday life.
It's like you know how you can sit and
edit stoned,
you know,
and you get high and then it makes you
more creative and it's more fun.
Well I don't like talking to people.
Usually when I'm still in.
Like if I,
if I get stoned and talked to my mom,
it's going to be worse than if I was
now.
You know what you mean?
Totally.
But for me,
what it is,
is just an experience thing.
It's just like you got to get
comfortable with the experience and when
you've been doing comedy for like,
I've been doing it 22 years almost.
Yeah,
that'd be 22 years in August.
That's a long ass time,
man.
When you're doing it for that long,
it really does become just like another
thing you do in life.
It doesn't,
doesn't freak out.
So when you get high it's like you just
tune into that thing better.
So I can just fucking connect to it
better.
No.
When did you start smoking weed?
Because I think when I first met you,
you weren't a weed smoker?
No,
not at all.
As a matter of fact,
I thought it was for losers.
And what,
what,
what made that change?
I saw,
I tried it.
Um,
you know,
Eddie Bravo is the dude who turned me
onto it because Eddie and I were,
we met at Jujitsu and we were going out
to lunch or talking about some shit.
And he's a smart dude.
I was like,
we had really similar philosophies on a
lot of different things on,
on politics and on the way the world
works and like how strange everything
is.
Like a very curious,
very similar point of view to mine,
but he would talk about getting high all
the time and doing,
making this music and shit.
And I was like,
how the fuck is that good for you man?
I was like,
Pontus makes you fucking lazy.
Like that's what I thought.
And he's like,
no,
no.
That's all propaganda.
It's all,
if you don't know what you're doing,
if you smoke the wrong kind of weed,
if you smoke too much,
if you do it when you're drunk,
you know,
you associate all these negative things
with it,
just try it.
So I said,
all right,
fuck it.
Come on,
let's try it.
And from that day,
from that day getting high,
I realized I'm like,
Whoa,
this is crazy.
Here's this.
There's a plant that gives you an
altered state of consciousness that
actually makes things seem more.
You're more sensitive to things and it
makes you more aware of.
It feels like some weird like
intelligence enhancer,
it feels like it makes you.
It makes you dopey,
and the fact that sometimes you get so
obsessed with one idea,
you can't multitask at the same time.
So if you get how to fucking,
you know,
how do you spell someone's name and your
phone or if you can get some weird shit,
you forget what you were talking about
because there's just so much going on.
It's such a flood and it's just the.
The,
the key to the experience to using it as
to learning how to relax and learning
how to get rid of all the shit that
makes you paranoid.
Because when dudes get paranoid,
when you freak out about shit,
you should be freaking out about that.
Whatever the fuck it is,
you're freaking out about.
When you.
When you get high,
that is something that you've put in the
back of your head and you're avoiding
and it's an issue that you need to
resolve and once you do resolve those
issues,
once you don't have anything fucking
with your head.
Once you let come to terms with who you
are in this life and and try to put it,
put out good energy and you feel
comfortable with it,
then you can ride that bitch.
Then when you get high you can fucking
tune into it all so you can get really
high and not be paranoid and instead of
being paranoid,
you learn how to like,
let go and tune into some sort of a
higher state of truth than what you're
normally able to experience.
You can see things in a perspective that
doesn't seem to be available to you in a
sober state as much as you meditate,
as much as you try to release.
Even if I'm in an isolation tank,
there's something about there's a
connection that plant gives you to
something else,
you know,
and I think we just,
we have it categorized as something
that's like silly and we have it
categorized as something,
you know,
a man,
we watched this movie,
it was awesome.
Which is totally true to you can do
that,
especially if you smoke like couch weed,
but you can also smoke weed and and
figure out the universe.
I mean Carl Sagan used to smoke weed
every day.
Why it is I think the propaganda that
went along with the people who didn't
want you thinking like that,
you know,
to a point with reefer madness and all
that stuff.
It's like when you get high or you do
shrooms and all that stuff,
you start seeing things differently.
Yeah.
And you know,
people will go Fulcan rogen and his
bullshit part propaganda.
Like what are you talking about bro?
You're getting brand damage,
you're focusing,
you're losing your mind.
You know the people who say that all of
them don't smoke weed.
It is just smoking weed.
They don't give a fuck.
People that bash iphones because they
have iphones,
apple,
somebody put a thread up on the
underground the other day,
Tom lawler filthy tom law or though the
fighter.
I said,
why should I tell me why I should buy a
Mac?
And you know,
people like you,
if you're gay,
sell these dudes like get fucking upset
at Max,
you know,
weird.
There's so many retards out there.
It Bro,
there's so many retards and all of them
just need.
They needed to be raised better.
All of them,
all of them were raised by other
retards.
And it's just a cycle to thin the herd.
Don't want,
you know,
what we gotta do,
we gotta figure out a way to fucking
make people like develop and grow and
evolve and catch the fuck up because
these dumb asses,
having kids,
these people that are just their life is
a fucking holy rack.
The relationships are filled with
fucking yelling and screaming and chaos
and all sorts of dysfunctional bullshit
and drugs and alcoholism and in hate and
anger.
And these kids grow up in that and then
they're fucked.
You know,
they grew up in that.
They get,
they get poor programming when they're
young.
So they never figured out how to really
see the world and healthy and loving
way,
you know,
they're always need either always angry.
There was always negative.
Like that's how they're fucking
programmed.
And they're going to program kids just
like them,
unless something snaps them out of it,
whether they get addicted to meditation
and become a monk or getting into
martial arts or you know,
learn,
learn how to do a fucking sport where
you can get out of here wherever the
fuck you are you're at and you know,
and,
and figure things out for yourself.
But you need to like really fucking
rethink your whole world when you're
raised like that for most people.
That's so fucking hard.
Yeah,
the middle of nowhere.
I think people are just like,
they're just slowly dying.
It's just like to go out there and learn
about all this stuff takes effort and I
just saw my chapter.
People don't want to do that.
They don't,
they're too lazy and they want you to
think the way they're thinking.
Well,
you couldn't do want you to think the
way they're thinking.
That's what they want.
That's what being a right wing person is
all about.
That's what people who are nationalism
internationalism,
that's what it's all about.
It's all about you thinking like we're
all part of this one thing.
Drink blue moon to fuck.
Just still put your quick.
There's the Christian diction who's
booked on crystal ball juice.
Yeah.
It's so low.
Their idols crashes and Burns instead of
being like,
well,
maybe we don't have.
We don't see it right there.
Like,
I'll fucking get rid of him.
And you guys pops up saying they see it.
Right.
It's crazy.
Anybody you can't.
We have to talk this fucking thing out.
You can't say you have the answers.
There's too many questions.
It's impossible.
It's too tricky.
You never have crossed over and come
back.
You know.
Most of them have never even had
alternate experiences like psychedelic
experiences that they can add to their
model of the world.
You know,
there's altered states.
It can be achieved by fucking plants on
this that are growing here on this
planet.
Know if there really was God,
do you think it would just leave things
like that there.
I mean if God,
if there was a really,
it was a god and he had a plan.
If you think that,
then you really should believe in
psychedelics because they're there for a
fucking reason.
God's not just going to put some shit
that makes you have these beautiful,
loving,
positive,
incredibly mind expanding experience.
That's just a dumb coincidence.
You know,
that's just a dumb coincidence that that
grows on cow shit.
Like if you're religious,
you should be into psychedelic
experiences and if you into psychedelic
experiences,
the first thing you're going to say is
no one knows.
You can't know.
There's no fucking way.
There's no answers.
We all have to try to figure out what's
the best model of behavior for this
life.
What's the best way we can get by with
the most positive energy?
Because we don't know what the fuck am I
believe in Karma.
Yes.
It's real.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Fuck did I do.
I totally believe in.
It could be like,
it might not happen today,
tomorrow,
a year from now,
but it will come back.
Yes.
Here's my take on Karma.
I don't even think.
I think even the way we think of Karma,
we think of it selfishly,
that we think,
you know,
I don't want to do bad things because I
want,
you know,
good things come back to me.
So I'm going to do good things.
So the good thing come back to me.
You know,
we,
I mean even the term Karma,
like the way people use it up,
that's Karma.
See what happened to him.
Karma.
It's almost like self justifying,
you know,
I think the way to look at it is that
you,
and this is all shit that I like decided
on after I had dmt trips,
is that I think all the energy that you
put out,
so it's sort of your choice.
It's sort of your choice to be positive
and when you're positive,
positive will resonate more positive.
It's,
you put yourself in a,
in a group of people,
you know,
a,
a think group that are all like that.
When you're positive and you're like a
friendly,
loving person,
you're going to naturally have that kind
of behavior from your friends.
You're going to,
they're going to feel like they can be
that way with you and that's going to
ripple out.
And so all the people that are gonna be
in your circle after awhile,
we're all going to be like loving
positive.
Cool people and that's possible,
man,
we can all do that.
We literally can all do that.
It's just hard to do.
You know,
it's hard.
It's hard to find cool people.
It's hard to find people that you can,
you can open up with and you'd be cool
with it and you get to a point in your
life where you can,
can,
you want them to be successful.
You want them to be happy,
want great things for them,
like literally want that for them as
much as you would want it for you.
You know,
instead of thinking of Karma as like,
you know,
you do good thing.
So do good things.
Come back to you.
It's more to me like your energy.
We're all energy and when you,
you resonate positive energy and when
you push forth positive energy is
fucking hippie and crystals and yoga
beads as that sounds.
I really think that shit is,
is how the universe works.
I think if you're a negative negative
fucked up,
Shit's going to happen.
It's supposed to,
you know,
and I think a lot of the times when we
have negative content,
our life,
you know,
it's like,
it's almost like we are.
Life is a mathematical problem and some
things will come up in your life.
Male,
female,
whatever.
Job Boss,
whatever the fuck it is.
There's things that come up in your life
that are absolutely negative and it's
your job to figure out how the fuck to
get past this part of the game.
It's that simple.
You don't just say,
oh my fucking job sucks.
There's not.
My boss was a Douche,
so I'm getting fucking ulcers because my
boss is fucking always on my ass.
I'm always nervous.
No,
that's.
This is an intelligence test.
Okay.
You've,
you've reached a problem.
Yeah.
It might be very difficult to solve this
problem.
You might have children.
You might have obligations that you have
to think,
so this problem might take you a couple
of years to solve,
but it's your fucking job to solve this
problem.
Douche bag.
It's not your job to go to the doctor
and take a fucking pill,
makes you loopy,
and then you do go cocaine one night and
shoot up a fucking movie theater.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
you get your shit together,
son.
Get get your fucking shit together.
This life is a test.
It's all like little things that you
come across in your life.
You're going to fail,
you're going to have mistakes,
but that's all good.
That's what they're supposed to be there
for.
Everything's energy,
man.
Yeah.
I mean it sounds totally ridiculous.
Tubes and tunnels as I believe and I
believe it was tubes and tunnels.
Tron.
Yeah.
Tron,
you see toy story three d,
it was a dope.
I love it.
I hear it's awesome.
That is probably the best movie ever to
get as stoned as closest to.
I'm having a heart attack.
Get that stone.
Go see toy story three.
It's fucking crazy.
I just.
I know you might not.
I love animated movies really well.
Like did you like up dude?
It was better than up and that's saying
a lot because I love.
Fuck.
How great was up when your baked goods.
You're going to love this.
I saw the incredibles.
Hi.
It was so good.
It was magical.
Avatar high is the best movie in the
world.
You know what I.
I'm waiting for it to come out blue,
right?
Like a better ray versions I haven't
seen yet because they haven't seen it.
I've seen it.
I've seen it,
but no,
they released a stripped down blue ray
and then they're going to release like
an extended version blue.
Right?
Like in a couple months.
And so I'm waiting.
I'm not going to just go buy this frugal
shopper.
Well,
I don't want to buy three versions of
Avatar about him not winning the Oscar
gives a fuck man.
Really?
These are goofy jokes.
The,
the,
the idea that you're,
you're fucking,
you have awards that you'd give to art.
Who can,
who the fuck is he to say what is good?
There's shit that people like that I
hate.
You know,
there's women that thought sex necessity
to is the greatest movie in the history
of the world.
Would I have liked to?
Probably not.
Did you watch Kimmel last night?
No,
dude.
They ran out of power and they,
that's what was going on.
They all right.
So anyways,
I think I looked at it and I'm like,
that's completely the marketing,
you know,
that's completely like a good idea to
advertise the green Hornet trailer that
they premiered and stuff like that
because they,
it was weird because they were like,
we don't have power for the cameras,
but yet then they're in a room where the
tvs are on and the lights are on.
I'm like,
well,
I mean,
what's the,
what kind of cameras do not just
plugging a lot I guess.
And we can find out.
We can find out what it was.
Genius.
It was John Barris will tell us.
Yeah,
Don was on it last night.
He was taking the laptop and show him
like,
Hey,
Don calling don bears right now.
Do not release this information.
But what's weird is that that uh,
I bet that got so much ratings because
of that you don't have that little
gimmick and stuff like that.
The whole show was watching this use
stream on tv and it's brilliant because
what if,
what was he was doing it in photo booth
or whatever.
That Mac.
A Basic Mac program that comes with it.
Photo.
It's totally scam.
Scam.
I don't know because half of you wants
to go.
No,
this.
I could see this accident on television
and so the whole episode was filmed with
a Shitty Webcam,
you know,
on his Mac book and I'm like,
wait,
what if that becomes popular?
We start going backwards with our hdtvs.
We're now watching ustream shitty
videos.
No one.
I didn't mind it.
I mean I only watch a couple of minutes.
The sound is what got me.
It was awesome.
When I was A.
I was watching a fight and I shut it off
and I was getting ready to go to bed and
when I shut the light off,
the regular tv came on,
the fight was on the dvr and then it was
on and I was like,
what the fuck is going on here?
But it made me tune in
because I was like,
yeah,
it worked.
It worked.
Come off.
Watch how often do you actually watch
talk shows?
Do you want to talk to you about that
much?
I tivo.
I like wait for the youtube clips
because if like letterman said something
really hilarious,
it's going to be in a youtube clip.
I mean I don't have an hour and I tivo
them all and then if somebody says,
hey,
did you watch the Lenovo or whatever,
and I'm like,
oh,
watch that.
Then I gave you a lot at that time too
because I go up late.
We're isn't being friends with all you
comics because all of you like it can't
do anything except go to comedy clubs
every night.
Like he pretty much right off your life
at a comedy club every single night
because like I was going through some
tough times recently.
I'm like,
Hey,
who can I call?
No,
I don't want to see your show.
I've already seen it.
Hey,
how you doing?
Oh No,
I don't want to go see your show.
Like you guys never stopped.
Like,
Hey,
come to my show.
Come to my show.
It never stops.
Maybe you're just an awesome audience.
Members bring your camera,
Brian,
what the real problem is,
is that they have to go up.
I know that's the only way you can hang
out.
How do you,
how do you guys devote so much of your
life though too?
Because I'm not talking about like every
night,
especially weekends.
You have to work man.
I mean if you want to be a comic,
you got to work.
You,
you're a writer yourself,
producer,
you're the director,
you know,
if you putting out a shit product
directly affect,
you know,
reflects on you,
you gotta be careful.
You gotta work at it,
you know,
and stand up comedy man.
If I take a couple of weeks off,
I feel rusty doing it 22 fucking years
and I'd take a couple of weeks off and
I'm like,
Ooh,
I'm a little rusty here.
I'm not feeling this right though.
I was uh,
I was in Australia even though I was
gigging out there and I came back and I
did a store set and I got heckled right
out the gate and it went bad fast too.
It was like
goals or dark,
Bro.
There's something about heckling in the
store that leads much quicker to
violence and anger and like real
tension.
I've never had people throw shit at me,
but I've had two people throw things at
me at the store.
It's
so weird,
man.
And the,
the bouncers are all
emo fucks borders and fucking death cab
for cutie or something like that.
There's some big fuck in the,
in the,
the uh,
original room and he's yelling at
somebody like,
remember when he ultimately got knocked
out?
Knocked out holtzman.
Yeah.
Martin Lawrence was fucked up in the
audience,
but I don't know if he was fucked up.
I might've been added that part to it.
But in a big night for him though,
like ICM was down.
All the people from ICM,
it come down to see holtzman.
So they saw him get knocked out.
They saw the crazy.
Lawrence might've just changed his whole
career path.
Like,
no,
you're not going to become a movie star
band without change.
Holtmann's career path.
Well,
I mean,
what if those guys were like,
dude,
we love this comic.
They said they were like,
did he just got knocked out?
Yeah,
maybe,
I dunno,
you know,
Holtzman was the type of guy that would
kill kill comedians.
He would kill us,
but it was a lot of people that didn't
see it as a goof and they thought it was
just,
he was just this really Douchey,
angry man.
He didn't see how funny it was.
The main fucked up shit that he was
saying with that,
that character.
Now the comedy store doesn't work.
It doesn't,
it.
The comedy store is such a dark evil
fucking place for people that don't
know.
The comedy store used to be Ciro's
nightclub and Bugsy Siegel ran that
place in the fifties and the forties,
wherever the fuck it was.
What was that?
I think the forties,
forties.
Bugsy Siegel apparently had a bunch of
people murdered.
Yeah.
Shane.
And apparently,
you know,
everybody that works there has these
creepy fucking horror stores,
you know,
they all talk about ghosts and shit.
But that said,
almost everybody that works there is
crazy and does drugs with a,
the grants salt.
My friends always found funny about
ghost man is like,
I don't know if you ever watch,
um,
paranormal shows,
you know,
and those show up and they'll interview
the person and there'll be like,
you know,
and then fire came out of the walls and
the blood was everywhere and then
they'll do like dead time thing when see
that curtain move.
Yeah,
that's bullshit.
It's all night vision and a basement.
What's that noise?
Every show nobody ever goes on video you
have to do is fucking go to a cemetery
like midnight on Halloween and just go
find somebody that murdered wife or
something like that and start making fun
of her,
you know?
And like nothing will happen.
They'll go,
has ever killed anybody,
man,
you know,
do you like,
I've,
I was always taught that like ghosts.
Maybe we're like,
it's all energy man.
And maybe energy gets lost in some kind
of wealth transfer.
If you look at our existence on this
planet as it were in a frequency.
You know,
and this is,
I mean if you don't understand how this
works,
but quantum physicists believe that
there are 11 dimensions as the current
model of reality.
11 different dimensions.
Obviously we can't to intercede those 11
different dimensions and if we,
from what we know about like radio
waves,
think about like radio waves,
thinking about how,
you know,
97 point one is loud and clear
and I have to do is turn that dial and
you're on one.
Oh,
seven point nine.
Totally different music,
loud and clear.
It's like there are frequencies,
very specific frequencies.
If that exists with something as
intangible as radio waves,
how do we not assume that that doesn't
work with reality as well?
Maybe.
Maybe you know,
maybe there's so many different things
that are tuned in around us all the
time.
They're just on a frequency that we
can't detect and it doesn't interact
with this frequency,
but all this shit is going on together
in one big just fucking crazy cosmic
soup.
You know,
if that's the case,
shit,
anything's possible.
Ghosts,
there could be.
I mean,
what a ghost could be somehow or
another.
The energy of the experience of what
happened to them when they got murdered
or something like that,
you know,
because it's always like horror stories
always.
The guy had an awesome life and now he's
a ghost.
It's fucking brutally raped and murdered
and then they,
they roamed that house.
Maybe that experience maybe the
spiritual horror and shock and
terrorists so powerful that it actually
leaves like a,
like a,
you know when your monitor gets frozen
on a screen and then it like stays on
that image.
There's like the ghost of that image in
the background.
You know what I mean?
Because it got too much energy from that
one position.
It got locked into that one pattern and
so the old,
especially those old shitty screens
aren't turned in you.
You would burn in an image.
It's very possible that an image of
someone dying and extremely horrible way
is actually burned into the world.
But that said,
I think most people are completely
fucking full of shit and they're just
dumb.
They're just in basements.
Fucking goggles on.
Why is it always gay guys and fat chicks
do that shit,
but it's the same people that would be
into like goth music and spring,
the spring or breed.
It's the cheater breed.
It's all those shows that the same
breed,
you know,
that's a Brita human as there's always
people that are looking for something
mysterious,
you know?
That's why I love monster quest.
I got a little bit of that in myself
that like getting into like fucking
secret shit to.
Do you think sasquatch is real?
I mean,
I've gotten so far as like read.
I've probably read a dozen books on
sasquatch.
I tell there's no.
It's real might be,
but this is why I might be.
There's a.
there's an animal called gigantic
[inaudible] that lived in Asia and that
animal lived exactly where the same
Asians who came across the bering strait
and came to America and eventually
became the native Americans that they
came from the same place.
So if this animal,
this big gigantic eight foot tall
bipedal primate that actually lived.
If that was in North America,
if it came across the bering strait with
the people who's to say it didn't,
that could live in the Pacific northwest
like,
but actually seeing it by now,
we would've me,
you know.
Let me tell you something.
From living in the mountains and from
talking to people that live in the
mountains,
it's,
there's so many,
there's so many mountain lions are so
many bear.
There's so many fucking animals up there
and you rarely see them.
And the thing is when you do see them,
you see live ones,
you never find a dead one.
It's very rare because the forest eats
the fucking animals and if you're in a
place like the Pacific northwest,
have you fly over that area,
it's so dense like you don't realize how
vast the forest until you fly over
there.
It's basically a rain forest.
The Pacific northwest is incredibly
dense woods where nobody goes.
How the Loch Ness.
I mean it's like,
it's stupid.
Who Cares?
There's fucking killer whales in the
ocean.
They're real.
They're super intelligent.
They speak in dialects,
they save people.
The only time they murder peoples in
captivity,
those are real things that are killer
whales.
Save people,
save people.
Yeah.
No killer was ever killed anybody.
I don't care about the size or the loch
ness monster.
He just wrote that off that quickly.
Fish.
It doesn't do shit.
This guy might just be a person.
That tall guy that lives in.
I'm not totally sold on bigfoot.
I'm not sold.
I'm not saying that it exists on the
exact same level of bullshit,
you know,
like we would have found them,
but it's possible that with the loch
ness monsters,
they think it's might be Aplysia sore
that somehow or another got landlocked,
but there's not enough evidence.
They've looked really hard.
They've done sonar searches of the
entire ocean floor or the entire lock
floor.
See,
it's not like the woods and in,
you know,
in Oregon or something like that where
you really can't get in there.
It's not like that.
It's just one specific body of water so
they can do a pretty thorough job of
looking inside for anything big that
swims and if there's a fucking thing
that's been around for a long time,
chances are there's a family of them.
He spot a few of them and then that spot
and shit,
they don't find anything that if you
only get a blip,
probably a fucking turtle farts or
something like that.
It doesn't.
It doesn't interest me because it
doesn't do anything to the primate thing
interests me because of the.
The idea that this thing could be
superintelligence just like champs and
avoid people.
You know who the Congo.
Okay.
There's,
there's an animal in the Congo that
they've just recently discovered
recently being they.
They confirmed it in the 1990.
It's called the Bondo ape or the billy
ape and what this is is a gigantic
chimpanzee.
They're much bigger than regular.
Chimpanzees is like six feet tall and
they stand upright and they have gray
hair.
A lot of them have gray hair and they
fucking sleep on the ground like
gorillas.
They don't give a fuck.
Nothing fucks with them.
And there's two types of chimps that
the,
uh,
the people that live in that part of the
jungle,
they call them,
the regular ones are tree beaters and
lion killers.
There's tree beaters in lion killers and
these guys were recently in the Congo
filming this fucking thing.
This is a bonafide,
absolute real animal.
They have DNA,
they have photographs,
they have video,
they have bones,
they have a first samples,
they have all these different things
that show that it's some sort of a,
some sort of a new species of
chimpanzees and it's fucking living in
the Congo.
They know where it is.
They know where it is right now,
but they didn't fucking know about this
until this wasn't confirmed until like
the nineties,
like [inaudible] 94,
I think it was when they all came to a
consensus and said,
hey,
this is a real animal,
will have a giant chimp that sleeps on
the fucking ground.
They have video of one evening a Jaguar.
Okay.
These fucking guys came upon it and it
was eating a Jaguar.
They don't know if it killed the Jaguar,
not but the local say they do.
But what the fuck,
man,
what the fuck?
That's a real animal.
That's a real animal that lives in the
Congo.
It's very possible that there could be
some super high,
high intelligence level primate that
survive just with a couple hundred of
them in a very small part of the woods
and they have amazing hearing,
an amazing sense of smell,
and they just avoid humans because it's
too difficult to get to them.
So they stayed tightly packed in.
There's plenty of fucking food.
If they're vegetarians there,
which they probably are.
Otherwise they wouldn't be eating
people,
you know.
Sure.
Right.
If there were predators at all,
there had been people and then we would
hear crazy stories about the meeting
people,
but everybody that sees them,
nobody gets eaten in the middle of the
night.
Nobody gets their tent pulled apart.
So most likely they're like gorillas.
Gorillas are vegetarians to.
So they're probably just a big fucking
vegetarian animal that lives in the
woods.
It doesn't mean that exists,
but it's fucking possible.
What was the animal that they thought
was the mermaid?
And you're like,
how lonely were you when you thought
that this fucking beast was a woman?
I saw it in Australia.
I can't remember the name of it.
I don't even know.
It's not a manatee county.
What is it?
Got?
Damn it.
I don't know.
Google.
Google that shit,
son.
I don't.
I've never even heard this.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
there's an actual animal that they
basically thought we were mermaids.
Like those guys are so desperate out
there.
They're looking for chicks wherever they
can find it.
Two,
could you imagine?
I mean,
look,
we live in Hollywood,
pneumonia fucker.
Rubber Pussy Convention.
A horny those dudes be when the brown
boats for like six months.
Fuck the pussy.
Were you like,
I don't know about rubber one.
You one.
You mean the flashlight?
No,
no,
I have no shame.
Just stuck on my deck and squirt inside
it and that was it.
I was like,
wow.
That's pretty good.
Good Dude.
You bust a strong.
Not Strong.
Is that a man?
I know it was a different name though.
I'll find it out.
Yeah.
No,
it's a different name.
I'll tell you.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's not a manatee
Sam triply making shit up.
Caught them,
ladies and gentlemen.
No way man.
That shit kind goes saying manatees.
What kind of balls those guys have to
have that lived in like fucking England
when we get on boats and go across the
ocean,
think about that shit on.
Look at a map,
look at where the fucking continents are
and think about how fucking crazy you
would have to be to take a boat,
fill it up with enough food to hopefully
make it to the other side.
Yesterday had a,
do you have a stuffed up pitch with food
and ration that shit off and people
would die because they didn't get enough
vitamin C,
they'd get fucking scurvy and it right
away.
It's crazy.
And they just throw them in the water
about the uh,
the uh,
pirate cook.
Did you read that?
No,
it was on Huffington Post.
One of these smiling pirate cooks turned
on all of his crew and he gave all the
hostages guns.
He's feeding them because you know,
they were getting abused.
He was feeding them.
They started hearing the pirates talk
about harvesting their organs.
So he got them all like guns and they,
they attacked the,
killed all the pirates.
Now here's what's crazy is no country
will accept this pirate.
They won't accept them.
So this guy who ratted out his friends
and gave them the guns,
they won't accept him.
You say ratted or save some people.
Either one.
Yeah.
Well you just decided it was too much or
maybe he didn't like them.
Maybe they were Douche bags.
Maybe he's a Douche bag to the brow,
you know,
and that they were just douche bags as
well and they didn't get along.
You know,
it might not be a good guy,
bad guy.
Situation.
Like say some people who were hostages.
Sure he did.
But maybe it's because he hated those
other dudes.
This motherfucker already keep enough
money this month.
Uh,
fuck I showed them.
I flick when you come back for the food
I give you,
can I give you a gun?
You highlight pirate living with me.
You don't need to play pool or alarm
system.
Yeah.
But maybe he decides to kill you.
Fuck your girlfriend.
Maybe duct tapes a pistol inside your
mouth.
Like fucks your woman.
How about that crazy shit dude.
That guy's living wild.
Son has a fucking pirate and all over
the seat.
I bet you know.
Never give a fuck.
You clean it out.
Clean.
Cleaned my clock.
Cleaned my think I fuck with you now.
Clean.
You have to clean his dick.
He pisses and it makes it clean.
You'll be a have a Somali pilot in your
house.
That's like living with a wild man bro.
They're wild bro.
They don't have any future this.
When you living in Somalia like what's
the,
what's the future?
They don't give a fuck.
They're ready to die.
You know they don't give a fuck dude.
They're out.
Jack and ships.
They're getting a little rowboats with
machine guns and rocket launchers and
they're climbing on board.
Big giant ships and Jack and everybody.
They are fucking locators,
man.
Well that's what they say about a
terrorists who blow themselves up.
It's not really religion.
It's more about.
They just have nothing going on there.
There's this book called a why two
beautiful people have more daughters.
It's about evolutionary psychology and
they talk about that.
It's not really religion,
it's more about that.
These guys feel,
yeah,
they have,
they have no chance to make money and
they have no chance of meeting a woman
because they're so broke and like all
the rich guys get all the chicks,
so it's like that's why they get
promised like,
hey,
you get all these virgins and you get
all this stuff.
Those are also the people that you can
get to doing something because they just
want to belong.
They want to be special.
They want to be treated like they're
special and you know when they're
getting someone to become a suicide
bomber.
If you ever looked at like there was a
special.
I don't remember what show was on,
but they were in somewhere in the Middle
East and they have this school and on
the school they had these photographs of
these people that have blown themselves
up and we're all this religious writing
on it and there was a big sign above the
school that says today's children are
tomorrow's holy martyrs.
And like God damn like they're there.
The attention that they give to those
children,
they make them out to be heroes.
They make them out to be special that so
many people want people's love and
affection and they want.
They want to be special so badly that
they're willing to do almost anything.
Yeah,
it's crazy,
man.
It's like,
don't you wish you go back in time and
just rewrite some of the religious
books?
Take out all the asshole stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like throughout
time people have always bullshitted
other people to control them.
I mean,
it's so simple.
It's so obvious.
It's existed forever.
What's amazing though is that the
bullshit that worked like 2000 years ago
still works today just because it's
written,
you know,
it's just,
this is what,
this is what it is.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
when you,
when you really get into it and you
start reading about women being treated
as second class citizens,
condoning slavery,
condoning murder,
all the crazy shit that's in religious
texts,
all that nutty shit that people still
suck on it.
Two thousand years later,
years later,
I always thought that religion was more
like a,
just like early science,
like people trying to explain,
just laying down the law,
man,
it's laying down the law and laying it
down.
It wants to stay.
I listen to you,
cause if you don't go down,
that's what it is.
It's like you've got to keep dummies in
line with crazy talk and that crazy talk
spread and it became a good way to keep
social order intact.
Key people,
you know,
in small towns,
man,
go to the church,
everybody's all happy and friendly and
it makes everybody together,
you know.
But if you look at like all these people
that are doing fucked up things in the
world,
you know,
whether it's suicide bombers were Somali
pirates,
they come from somewhere that fucking
sucks.
And that's what it all boils down to.
Their life fucking sucks though.
Somali pirates did you know the whole
story behind that?
Why they became pirates?
Dude,
they call themselves the people,
but if they call themselves the fucking,
the volunteer coastguard of Somalia,
that's what they call themselves.
And what happened was European ships and
companies and I believe some Americans
to we're dumping waste into their waters
and fucking up there fishing man.
And they found out about this because
there are fish were dying and what they
did was kidnap a boat that was illegally
trespassing through their waters and
they demanded a ransom because this was
one of the boats that was polluting the
waters.
And these guys were fishermen,
man.
There were fishermen that had their
livelihoods fucked up and taken away
from them.
So they turned to crime and they started
jacking people because they've got so
much from the first boat.
They just turned it into a business and
now they just jack people constantly.
Dudes.
You're getting jacked all the time,
man.
If you.
There are hundreds of miles out to sea
just looking for people.
Man,
what do you think about the 16 year old
girl?
That's my whole point about saying her
around the world.
It's like,
man,
when you leave America,
it's a whole different game to women's
parents are so foolish.
That's so foolish.
There's one thing to let some experience
someone something.
There's another thing to put someone out
in the wild just to get it.
What are you going to get a rush out of?
The fact that he made it across,
you know,
you did something that could kill you
mean one of the benefits.
Is it so difficult and you did it.
She's amazing.
She did something.
You did something that I can do in a
plain stupid you can get in a plane and
that can be across that ocean and 10
hours.
Why the fuck would you spend five weeks
in a sailboat that's retarded.
That's not a smart way
because that's a hell of a facebook
status.
That's why you know,
that's all she's thinking about it like
I until
they going to do it,
it's gonna be so cool.
And where do you go from there?
I mean,
you're 16.
You keep going around the world.
What do you do next?
These assholes are getting hot,
hot air balloon guys over.
If I stay out around the road,
whatever you want to get wet this with,
this wants you to treat her.
She's special.
She's doing something special that
people are crazy.
They're nuts.
It's a crazy fucking desire with chicken
San Diego over that.
She's like,
would you send a 16 year old boy?
I'm like,
before 16 year old girl.
Yes.
I would send a 16 old boy before 16 year
old girl,
but I wouldn't send a 16 year old
either,
but I love my boy that I raised and I'm
going to put him in harm's way.
I would tell them,
listen,
man,
I don't want to be alone in the woods.
If you want to do something scary,
let's get you involved in some
competition.
Okay?
You don't want to fucking wrestle in
high school.
You want to.
You want to do some boxing and
kickboxing or something crazy.
Wanted to fight some MMA fights.
You want to do something crazy?
Let's do something that we can control
you.
Not going to put you in the fucking
ocean.
That's nuts.
All right.
I understand the,
uh,
the rising above,
like accomplishing crazy things,
doing things that appear to be
impossible.
They give you more of an understanding
of yourself.
They don't just give you this rush.
They give you an understanding of what
you're capable of.
They give you more confidence,
it gives you more you,
you,
you get a sense of what you're capable
of performing.
What you're capable of doing under
pressure makes you more,
you know,
like there's a quote that I read once
about taekwondo,
that fighting and competing and in
Taekwondo,
it elevates your human potential.
You know,
like it,
it gives you,
you have more potential because you've
already experienced harder,
more difficult things.
That's all well and good.
I understand that,
but fucking putting yourself in the
ocean and putting yourself in a position
where,
look,
there could be some shit happened to you
that you have no way of escaping.
There's no way getting it out.
You're gonna get a nice thrill because
you're going to put your life in danger,
but the reality is you're just getting
from one place to another.
That's all you're doing.
You're doing it old school,
you're just getting from one place to
another old school.
That's all you're doing.
You know,
it's so stupid.
It's like,
you know,
if someone chose to walk across America
and they starve to death along the way,
we should.
We feel bad for them.
What the fuck are you doing?
What do you.
What is southwestern New York?
It's like fucking 300 bucks.
I mean,
come on,
man.
Really,
you're going to walk across the country
and clearly agree with you fucking
asshole.
This is crazy parents there.
I mean,
you've got to push your kids to a point.
You have to push your kids.
You know people don't push it out to
push your kids.
Well,
I mean you gotta think you'd give them
some discipline and you know,
but you,
you teach them that with risk and with,
you know,
with work become come satisfaction.
You get to achieve something and that
satisfying and it makes you understand
and appreciate yourself better.
It makes you understand people better.
It makes you function better.
It's more like.
It's like lifting weights.
You lift weights,
you get stronger,
you get stronger.
You can pick things up easier.
It's that simple.
Wouldn't life you take on difficult
tasks.
You take on difficult,
difficult things that caused you to
think because your mind to spend caused
you to react quickly caused you to make
good choices that elevates your human
potential.
It's really that simple.
Nope,
I agree.
People don't do shit,
man.
Oh,
your phone motherfuckers that shit.
Of course it is.
You get it on your laptop.
I saw it,
but we all have mics.
Yeah,
but you're on your computer.
You don't still here.
That's a phantom sound son.
Phantom.
Speaking of phones tomorrow I found.
Have you guys been watching?
They're looking at the reviews.
The reviews are for G.
I'm scared.
The reviews are fucking amazing,
man.
I'm thinking att and t service is going
to hit an all time shitty low and so
that hopefully not.
But you know,
one of the cool things that all the
reviews are saying is how great the
video calling works in.
Like it's just perfect.
Like it works a video.
You could switch from front to back
camps.
So like if you're talking to me and you
go,
oh my God,
look at this guy,
he's doing this,
you know,
and it'll switch to the front of the
camera.
Apple is the future.
It is just crazy.
They're masters at marketing their
masters or getting people excited about
their products.
Yeah.
Oh I am.
I mean the phones,
what else do you use most everyday?
A phone.
Oh,
you're going to buy the first one.
You know,
not to buy the first one.
I mean you're,
you're going to buy like right out the
gate and then two weeks later it's going
to be like half price,
but not logic.
You should never buy anything.
Just wait.
The iphone,
stolen iphones don't change price at
all.
Like throughout the whole year.
It's usually almost exactly the same
thing that they weren't crazy about.
I think.
Yeah,
it was the iphone where like all these
guys wait in line.
They bought it for like a gazillion
dollars.
Oh,
the first iphone,
it was half price.
They flipped out when it first came out
with the price.
When the first iphone came out,
it was $100 more and then they dropped
it $100.
They gave everyone $100 back.
Didn't they recently lowered the price
of the three g or they're always doing
that because they're still selling that,
but they're still selling the second
generation one for like 49 bucks or
something like that.
And she says,
I am son now,
but don't get the new shit.
New Shit drops.
A little,
little frugal shopper.
Pablo Escobar son,
I gotta I gotta sell you a super vhs
real speaking of frugal shopper.
Do you guys hear about that?
A fucking federal judge that blocked
the,
uh,
he obama to put a moratorium.
It was trying to put a moratorium on
offshore drilling.
So this federal judge drops it,
you know,
he won't.
He blocks the moratorium and everybody's
like,
what the fuck?
Who is this guy?
This guy's crazy.
The Obama says he wants to stop oil
drilling.
There's a giant fucking hole where oil
is leaking out of the ocean.
Were like,
hey,
we might have a fucking problem here.
We gotta make sure this is ruining the
ocean for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of miles.
Anyway,
it turns out this federal judge has
stock in the company and in Trans Ocean
they have stock his stock at five
different companies that are involved in
the selling business.
Wow.
This motherfucker can literally profit
from his own decision.
How crazy is they should not be allowed
to do this.
Should not be allowed
to have money.
If that guy,
if that guy was on the case,
they should have said,
I,
you know,
we see that you have stock in this,
in this company that could,
you know,
in your decisions could adversely affect
you financially.
So we're going to remove you from this
case.
I mean,
that's,
that's what rational person like with
everything though,
like if you win a prize at,
wait,
are you,
do you work for NBC or any of its
affiliates?
You know,
that's how like everything always is
with everyone else except the president
is not as voided from it.
That's weird man.
How these guys have this detach,
detach from just humanity.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just straight evil.
Anybody that would think that the oil
business knows exactly what they're
doing and that this couldn't happen
again.
It's crazy.
Just because it's only happened a few
times in history,
it doesn't mean that these things are
deteriorating at a rapid pace and that,
you know,
the ones that have been around for a
long time,
we don't know how long they're gonna
last things happen.
Things fuck up,
you know the whole,
there's other wells out there that are
built like this one.
They say,
you know,
the whole deregulation thing.
It's so ridiculous.
Like what the market needs.
Deregulation.
It's like,
it makes no sense.
That's like saying we don't need laws
because we'll just regulate each other.
Well,
you know,
we get crazy too and say,
look,
you know,
we need to lower the pressure labor to
compete.
We have to go to China.
We have to go,
what the fuck are you talking?
We don't have to at all.
No,
you don't have to at all.
You just kind of stopped being too
greedy.
That's it.
You're going to get less profit,
but you're going to get a fucking.
What you're selling is a product that's
not made on people.
People's fucking souls.
You know,
you're,
you're going to sell a product that's
not poor people that live in a fucking
village and in China and then they have
to look at what was it,
Foxconn and we talk about all the time.
It's fucking company that makes iphone
parts and shit.
Dude.
They got people killing themselves left
and right over there who left and right.
They're literally shutting down all
their plants because there's so many
suicides and there's so much scandal.
These people are working like God knows
how many hours a day they're living on
the site.
You know?
That's.
That's what companies are doing,
man.
Companies are going to people like that.
That's the iphone too,
but Walmart's to worst to that company
makes the iphone.
Yeah.
Or at least parts of the iphone.
No warrants the worst.
Yeah,
man.
[inaudible],
they go.
They're like,
I don't believe that hype at all.
I think Walmart does a lot.
Like you either can see that point of
yeah,
Walmart comes in and they don't pay
anything,
but I also see a walmart fucking
striving for jobs and that go into these
towns.
Really disagree with that.
It's like,
first of all,
what they do is they keep driving down
the price and everything,
so eventually these people who produced
the goods they buy are going to have to
almost go to slave labor.
I think it's either or.
I don't think either one of you guys is
right,
both right,
but what what Walmart does is it comes
in to a community and it basically has
the lowest prices,
right?
So it puts mom and pop stores the pops
and all this stuff out and then seems
like a good idea and they don't pay a
real good wage to work there to what?
Go to Walmart.
Like that person makes six bucks an
hour.
The other jobs gone.
You got to go
work somewhere.
But before that,
before that,
there was no jobs that didn't exist.
Those 300 jobs at blacksmith goes out of
business right here.
But you know what the big thing is that
retail is dead no matter what.
So Walmart could be doing all they want
to,
but guess what?
Walmart ain't as cheap as fuck.
And Amazon,
Amazon.
Amazon is not his fucking growing like a
monster.
I buy groceries now on Amazon.
I'm buying coconut water by the case.
You know,
I don't even need to be a costco member
or any of that because they sell the
same shit now.
And you don't have to be a costco
delivered to your house,
they deliver it right to your house and
you can put it on schedule like I want
this every two weeks,
you know,
automatically ship going somewhere and
buying something helps your community.
Would you do that to a point?
But I'm also not going to pay $300 more
for a fucking tv,
you know.
And I'm like,
sorry,
fucking think of what's next in your job
career.
If you can't sell this TV cheaper than
this person,
I'm not going to buy it simple.
I don't think that people have an
obligation to be able to continue to
sell you things.
I think if something comes along the
consultings for much cheaper and at the
same quality,
if it's the same product.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
I,
I'm loyal to friends and I,
there's a couple of businesses that I
support that I know charge more than
they probably should for things like our
pot doctor,
but I don't care,
you know,
it's just like I have a sense of loyalty
to them,
but I've got some discretionary income
if you don't man,
300 bucks is a lot of fucking money.
And why would you pay $3?
Was being generous.
That's 300 bucks plus no tax plus free
about that,
but just can't get the kind of deals
that Walmart can,
you know,
tough shit man.
This,
I think it's either or.
It's.
I can see both points of view.
I see Brian's point of view where it
helps communities and it brings in jobs
and shit.
But I can see your point of view that
it's like,
well,
you're given these people this mediocre
life and they fucking.
They don't really save jobs because they
put some businesses under.
It's okay man.
It's all just change.
Just normal.
You know?
There's no good or bad.
See,
some people just aren't meant to be
doctors and lawyers.
And when you take away all their
opportunities to like build stuff on,
what else?
Is there a true though?
No,
you don't.
You just have to offer a service that
other people aren't offering for less.
It's not.
You can't
just have to figure it out.
You have to figure to figure it out
because if whatever you're doing,
if Walmart can get it cheaper,
you have to figure out either how you
could get it cheap or have a service
that,
that Walmart doesn't work.
My family's been in this business for 30
fucking years.
If you say it's okay for Walmart coming
to our town where we grew up,
you don't own the town,
you don't want a patch of dirt.
You don't own the rights to sell what
you're saying about that.
But it's like it goes back to like
everybody's like capitalism and free
enterprise.
Well this isn't what it was like 200
years ago.
You know,
when everything started to definitely
says it was mom and pops.
Now you got these huge corporations.
Like when,
when the Supreme Court says that a huge
corporation is like an individual,
while they're not a kazillion billion
dollars behind them.
You're talking about for a campaign
contribution.
Even in the
market though,
you're like,
we'll find a way to sell for less than
Walmart.
Well,
you never can because they buy in such
huge.
Yeah.
But that's not even it down.
I was saying you didn't have to do that
or you have to find a new service at
that Walmart doesn't offer like that.
Like if you're selling phones.
All right.
I will have a cell that you're the same
phone.
It's gonna be a little more.
But guess what,
I'm going to be coming to,
you know,
a tech support giving you this.
I'm going to,
I'm gonna you know,
anytime you need to get a new computer,
bring it in and I'll fucking transfer
all your contacts over there.
Fucking walmart ain't going to do that
shit.
You got to change with the Times.
You know what I mean?
These stores that I went in the other
day too,
like this store and I bought a Webcam
just because,
uh,
the,
the one at best buy,
they were sold out.
So I just like,
all right,
I'll go to this little mom and pop
electronic store.
And they had like an old version of the
Webcam.
It was dusty,
you know,
I'm like,
I'm just sitting here going like,
this is an old product that a fuck.
It's the same price as the new product
at best buy.
But you know,
I didn't even want to even buy it
because what?
They can't even turn enough product to
where they're shit they're selling is
outdated.
It's not current shit.
And so I'm like,
that's a problem.
It's not,
it's not Walmart's far as the change of
times.
It's Amazon,
it's all this.
And if you think you're going to have a
retail store in today's times,
you got to really fucking start using
your brain because you need to offer a
service that fucking,
I can't Amazon just going to kill you
regardless.
And then we're not even care about
Walmart and Amazon's gonna kill Walmart
eventually.
You know,
big corporations aren't killing all
businesses.
You're always gonna have like
restaurants that are great restaurants
because you know the cook is awesome.
He's always got interesting stuff to eat
there.
You're not going to get that from some
fucking chain.
You know,
some corporate chain you're going to get
like there's gonna be places of you're
always going to want to go do that,
have personality to them to have flair
that offer a certain environment or
ambiance.
But as long as the way things are
continuing to go,
the way they're going,
there's so many fucking people in this
world.
There's so many people.
These corporations get so big because of
that.
There's so many,
so many people to pull under.
You know,
there's so much to go after.
It doesn't seem like that's a trend
that's going to stop.
I don't see the idea of us,
you know,
going into little small groups and
businesses and you know,
and goods being distributed like that.
It's just going to continue to get
bigger and bigger.
What do you think of that woman who has
like 25 kids?
Which one is she should be shot?
Is that on that TV show now?
There's a will.
There's one TV show,
the family that I was like 19,
21 or something,
something like that.
I think that lady adopted this woman's
literally gave birth like,
oh,
that lady gave birth.
The lady on the TV show really like
super religious,
whole family.
Family's really cheesy,
but on a rigid schedule and serial
killers,
do you think are in their family?
They're all cool.
They're all friendly.
They're all happy.
They're all looking at the sense of
community they have down to a science.
I think serial killers come from
loneliness and abandonment.
Religious.
These people aren't abused.
They're.
They seem happy.
You know what I mean?
They're,
they're little loony with the religion.
Right.
Have hot sex orgies and we don't even
know about it,
but 20,
25 years and how dare you,
do you think they should like why do we
need 25 of them?
You know what man?
Here's what my deal is.
Way Better to have 25 people that are
nice and happy than 25 people that are
all fucked up and strung out on drugs
and fucking angry and shooting people
and whatever those people on that show.
I watched that show once the kids,
they might be all ate up with Jesus,
but you know what?
They're talking happy.
They're good people.
They're good people too.
That whole Jesus thing,
man is good for a lot of folks.
It's very whether or not you want to
question whether or not you want to be
objective about the source of all the
stories that are in the Bible and
whatever the bottom line is.
Most Christians are trying to be nice
people.
Yeah,
that's what it's all about.
It's a good thing,
man.
Imagine them without religion,
stuff like that before,
and people think I'm bullshitting and
um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm patronizing people,
but I'm not.
I think religion for a lot of people is
a good thing.
The idea behind it is all a good thing.
It's just believing that you've got the
fucking answers because you've committed
to it.
That's where the problem comes in.
The problem is when people get
aggressive with their,
their commitment,
they have a commitment and you'll have
to scratch my personal savior.
How about the fucking guy that we were
talking about them last week they went
to a.
he's in Afghanistan right now looking
for Osama bin Ladin.
They arrested him 52 fucking years old
on dialysis.
This looney toons saving up all his
money and one of the reasons why he's
going over there to kill Osama bin Ladin
is because he said bad things about our
God.
Dude,
where are your friends?
I just,
I don't trust anyone who's too into
anything to what it is.
Well,
even if I walk in and saw Jesus Christ
or Brett Farve,
whatever,
I'm like,
okay,
you're fucking shady.
Dude.
That's so true.
People that are fucking obsessed with
anything.
Everything in moderation.
You can be obsessed with fucking
checkers.
Men.
You can get obsessed with darts and you
get obsessed with anything and it can
become your whole world.
You know?
And if you get obsessed with Jesus and
you want everybody to believe in Jesus,
you believe in Jesus,
so you fucking want to run up to people
on the street and hand them books and
shit and tell them God.
Have you ever seen the movie king of
Kong?
No,
I heard it's awesome.
Oh,
they're obsessed with video games.
It's great to do those people exist to
real people.
We used to be a part of a clan and I
guess I still am.
You know,
you're in it for life.
But clam detriment.
I,
I used to play eight hours a day.
I got a t one line installed in my house
back when there was nothing else.
Well you can't get cable in my
neighborhood.
You can get ISD n which is only like
what is that 124 k or something like
that.
Not One hundred.
What is it?
50 slash 40.
I never got into like twice 56 K,
120 k,
something like that.
I think that's what I.
Sdn is maybe 140 and there wasn't
enough.
You're paying your latency between
service was too high,
so when you would play there'd be a lag.
It sucked.
So I had a fucking t one lines installed
in my house,
a business line.
It's like a thousand dollars a month
just so that I could play quake online
because I was playing every day.
She see this new pain ray that the US is
testing in Afghanistan.
I heard about it.
It's like this big fucking like laser.
It's out like a microwave
and it just makes you feel really hot.
It's going to be non lethal way for that
crowd control.
They're just going to start frying.
Or with Micromedex,
they talked about that.
I'm like 60 minutes and it was so
interesting because they were like,
you know,
they were demonstrating it and the
people they were using on where people
were like,
no war,
they had the no war sign.
I'm like,
that's who you're going to use it on.
Like they were old,
no size.
I'm like,
that's crazy dude.
Oh my God.
I got through not using it right now.
They just have it over there just in
case this the.
They want to use it
looking actively at the beginning of the
Iraq war,
I read a story online about coming up
with some sort of a weapon to make men
have gay feelings for each other to turn
it on the Iraqi troops they were,
when we invaded Iraq,
they were going to somehow or another
come up with some sort of a weapon like
they fucking spent money on,
you know,
in Afghanistan.
They have man loved Thursdays.
I've heard of that.
Yeah,
yeah,
I've heard that there's a lot of sex
going on over there.
They,
uh,
they,
they think women are for reproduction,
mentor for pleasure.
And every Thursday they go into the
mountains and they just asked,
blessed each other who had somebody.
A comic has a funny bit about that man.
Where the fuck is that?
That's awful.
Somebody went over to Afghanistan and
actually saw some guys fucking each
other.
Well,
it's like I was talking to some troops
when I did a us over there and uh,
you know,
they were trained in the Afghany troops
and like within their troop they had a
boy there in the group whose whole job
it was,
was the pleasure the guys and they,
they had to tell the troops not the same
thing because that's their custom and
not to get involved with that stuff.
You're royal penises,
clean tm.
I don't even know why we're fighting
over there,
man.
You go over there like this is a shit
hole.
Yeah.
We should just do the gdn and I hear
what they just discovered.
They discovered well over
$1,000,000,000,000
in mineral reserves,
previously unknown mineral reserves in
Afghanistan.
Oh look,
we just discussed.
We didn't even know was here.
Wow.
Crazy.
Well,
since we're here,
might as well start pulling the shit out
of the ground.
She's going to change.
Son.
Ever leave into.
Let me tell you some.
Afghanistan is going to be like Dubai in
20 years.
Okay.
We're going to have it over the whole
fucking country.
It's going to be democratized and
they'll have 2 million mile high
buildings.
Okay.
There's a trillion dollars worth of
minerals there that's going to be this
crazy mining town.
It's just like how we need gold with
these minerals we need for making
semiconductors and all kinds of other
shit that we,
we,
you know,
we use things for,
to construct stuff,
you know,
especially high tech stuff.
We use a lot of minerals.
It's like a trillion dollars worth of
stuff.
That's a thousand billion.
It's a lot of Sun.
Dude.
Shit's going to get Chris to do a joke
about.
The only person who could run Iraq is
magic Johnson because you know,
he made like almost a billion dollars in
like just redoing like apartments,
all that stuff.
And like,
you know,
give them like two weeks.
Fucking Baghdad would look like fucking
Orange County and whoever you put in
charge in there,
they're going to try to assassinate
anyways.
And you know,
we all know you can't kill Magic
Johnson.
Somebody tried.
So it's been a while since I did that
joke.
I couldn't remember how it went.
CIA planned to bomb Iraq with Saddam.
Gave video.
Oh,
that's different than.
We're going to make a fake.
Gave video.
That's funny.
The CIA did Photoshop.
Can you imagine?
We like like auditioning for that.
The US army soldier.
When you do to take down your pants.
I'll fuck this guy.
Yeah.
What do they do?
Kill you afterwards.
They,
if they're going to make a fucking fake
Saddam Hussein video,
they can't let you go.
If you're the type of person that's
willing to make a fake gay Saddam
Hussein video,
they can't trust you to keep your
fucking mouth shut at the government
paid you.
They're going to kill you,
man.
Well,
unless they kind of like a hey,
you know,
we let you in.
You just need to like don't ask,
don't tell.
But,
but we have a special program for what?
You get to be a soldier.
Lucky you.
You get to go get shot at after we went
to suck cock on video.
What a fucking gift.
Listen man,
I think they'd probably kill you.
I think they'd probably say,
listen,
we're going to do some gay.
Porn is going to be crazy.
It's we're going to pretend it's Osama
bin Laden,
or Saddam was saying or whatever.
And I met this guy,
doesn't even know he's doing it for the
military,
thinks he's doing a Persian look.
They shoot everybody in the fucking head
and throw them in the ocean and they
just disappeared.
No one ever hears about it.
That's fucking fucking surrounds Zmq
chicken.
Alright everybody out.
You know,
this general that just stepped up and
said all kinds of crazy shit about
Obama.
And you know,
there's Tris I think is,
I don't know what the fuck his name is.
He,
um,
they just made them resign.
So he resigned.
It turns out this is the same guy that
signed off on the Pat Tillman story.
He was trying to get everybody to
believe it's Pat Tillman was died by the
fighting the enemy when actually was
killed by friendly fire.
Same fucking dude.
He's an asshole.
He's like,
he goes over there,
it basically tells the troops,
uh,
this is going like shit.
And it's like you're the guy who came up
with a plan,
who you blame him.
He,
there's a lot of speculation.
I always listened to Opie and Anthony
today and people were calling in and
talking about it and they were saying
that they think that he might have tried
to,
uh,
he wanted to leave and he,
this was the way he could not just leave
but leave and get his point across,
you know,
that he calculated this and did it on
purpose.
So he made this big statement about them
because he knew it was going to be in
rolling stone and then he gets fired,
right?
Or gets forced to resign,
but then this issue,
whatever he said,
gets out there across the whole world
because of the fact that he opened his
mouth and in rolling stone and that they
reacted and that they fired him.
This becomes an issue that people want
to hear more about.
So then he gets a fucking book deal and
he'd get a book deal for several million
dollars.
If you're fucking smart,
he'll be on Fox News.
If it's legal.
I don't know what the legality is as far
as like what you're allowed to talk
about when you're allowed to talk about
it.
When you're a high level military guy,
you know,
in the United States army like he is,
but I would think that that would be a
fucking smooth move.
You know,
when you think.
I mean,
why just fucking quit?
You don't like it.
You don't like Obama.
Why quit?
Why not just make a stink mega stank?
Everybody knows you made a stink.
Write a book,
Bam sign.
You know,
just need a little fame baby.
Keep that ball rolling.
Well,
I mean look at Sarah Palin.
Exactly.
I was just gonna say that still in the
game.
So on that fucking election was two
years ago.
She was retarded.
Then she's still in the mix,
making millions,
making bank.
They're doing some crazy reality shows
series on hers,
like eight episodes for a million
dollars a pop.
I'm a POW POW,
POW.
That's why she got out.
She like,
I can't get money in sign raking day in
Alaska.
I did.
There is money and keeping the retards
happy.
She is the politics version of pro
wrestling.
If you go to watch pro wrestling,
there are thousands of people in those
stands and they're having a good fucking
time.
That bitch is the.
She's a female politician version of a
pro wrestler.
She says a bunch of retarded shit that
only retards agree with.
She riles them up.
They don't even know what she likes.
They know what she stands for.
She stands for someone who's not going
to think too much sense for someone
who's going to give basic values.
We're just gonna.
Get down on how's that whole hopey,
changey thing working out for you.
You know she.
She prides herself on being goofy and
people like that shit.
They connect to it and you're always
gonna.
Have that man.
You're always gonna.
Have that.
You're always going to have someone
steps up like that.
You're always going to have someone to.
If you,
if you all have to do is just get
yourself into the zeitgeists.
Get people,
start thinking about you and then keep
going and you can make a living off it.
Man,
they're fucking professional trolls.
Tomi,
me and cultures,
not a professional troll right on TV.
I want the bone or.
Dude,
did you really?
Yeah,
she's actually looking pretty hot.
Oh,
Sam triply.
How long does it.
I want to fuck the right out of her now.
You need to start drinking again.
You're getting beer goggles.
That's what I've heard.
This is incredible.
This really is true sex bomb.
Those who complain,
the military should make love not war.
May Be happy to know that at least on
one occasion,
the military scientists were searching
for ways to break down the enemy with
aching desire,
a sex bomb,
or in saucier headlines,
the gay bomb scientists consider
developing a chemical weapon with
Aphrodisiac qualities that would make
the enemy soldiers hopelessly physically
attracted to one another as to paralyze
their ranks and destroy morale.
Isn't that good?
Credible scientists wizard like some 18
year old guy from high school.
I'm a scientist.
I'm going to make some gay bombs out
there.
You know,
that's what the Pentagon hires.
It's not like they have access to the
best sign,
but they just said they talked about it.
They didn't actually do anything.
Listen to you,
man.
You don't even want to believe.
I believe they actually tried.
I do.
I believe.
I believe I don't put it past the
Pentagon,
but I also find it like if they even
were thinking about that,
they probably just said move.
We could make a bomb.
Maybe that's good.
All right,
that's cool.
They'll try and say,
hey,
they're saying aphrodisiacs right.
When they were together with men
and there was only men around,
they wouldn't be able to help
themselves.
That's the idea,
right?
You know,
look man,
if you break down what sexual desire is,
there must be some sort of a trigger in
our brains for sexual desire,
you know,
whatever it is,
some sort of a chemical trigger.
If they can
mimic that and find a way to get it into
people blast blasted out in a haze and
you inhale it as you breathe and all of
a sudden you can.
Thing they would do though is sell it.
The first thing they would do though is
they would be making money off that like
oil.
Why would they sell?
They knew as porn ever.
Why would they sell it when they can
make x amount of money from it?
When they could use it and take over
countries they could take over task to
fucking countries.
Okay,
and why would you sell it?
Because if you sold it then other people
would have access to it.
If you're going to use it.
If the military is gonna,
use it.
They're not going to,
you know,
the military is not going to turn into
some sort of fucking,
you know,
a vendor start selling some product.
You're going to have late night
commercials.
The theory that like the Samurais were
the days.
That's why they fought.
So I got my tattoo on my arm son
respect.
So just don't talk because it has so
much come in their mouth.
That's why pirates pirates dress
flamboyantly flamboyantly you know the
word they're all gay stop plants on.
Yeah.
That's was wearing.
Who the fuck else was wearing earrings
and shit back then?
Big Sashes and fucking pirates were
super gay and flamboyant silk shirts.
We're not taught.
Vikings and pirates aren't the same
thing.
Sam,
Sam tripling.
They're both on both our Nordic
warriors.
They're not gay,
they're fucking savages.
They.
That's why Nordic chicks are so hot
because they raped and pillaged all the
best ones.
They took everything they could find.
Just pure Alpha Male,
Arctic lust,
big fucking white Dicks of death,
just plundering and raping across the
world.
Big Difference between that.
Pirates pirates are sucking Dick and
wearing sashes.
They got crazy fucking patches over
their eyes.
Rainbow Birds,
birds,
rainbow.
What kind of bird?
Look at that.
Pirates are associated with parents.
What kind of a dude walks around with a
parent on shoulder?
A gay guy is sure.
If you see a dude with a parrot on his
shoulder,
he's.
Something's happened to him.
You know?
Maybe a dude made him jerk him off once
and he's fucking frozen patches.
Hate guys do magic tricks at House
parties.
Ooh,
that's rough.
I just went to the best house party
their day at South Park.
Had a house party and I went to it.
It was amazing.
Dude,
you have not been to a party until
you've been to one of these south park
parties.
He ever been to one.
Joe Did.
They probably spent like maybe $10,000
on just decorations,
like you walk in and you felt like you
were in Moulin Rouge,
like a circus or something like that.
They had fucking shooting galleries like
a,
like a carnival and stuff.
Those guys really have it done.
They're doing it right.
Those south park guys,
everything they do,
I love.
Every time they put something out on
level of America up the movie south
parking lot.
They were opening for tool.
What dvds they would run the a cartoon
before tool came out.
Oh,
you're talking about the Brian Boitano
one,
right?
Yeah.
The Brian Boitano one was the first.
Someone gave me that under the Christmas
card back when I was living in fucking.
I was living in Encino.
He was like,
God damn,
this is funny shit.
And then it became a show,
but every one of them will have that vhs
tape because he could probably Ebay
that.
I might have bills y'all.
I got a stack of old vhs tapes that may
or may not be interesting.
I found a few of them the other day,
but I'm like,
you know what?
All this shit is online,
so they sent it out as a Christmas card
through paramount or something like that
and not many people got that vhs tapes.
I'm sorry.
I fucking love the South Park movie.
That was just genius shit.
Team America is my favorite all time
movie of all time I think.
Yeah,
tea.
My favorite.
One of my funniest,
the funniest movie I've ever seen for
sure,
but the thing about south park was when
Saddam Hussein,
when they had Saddam saying being gay
with the devil and remember he had a big
rubber Dick and so funny that I saw that
movie in a theater full of Mexicans when
they called God the biggest bitch of a
mall.
You just felt the room energy turn.
They got mad.
Oh yeah.
Hilarious.
Like what?
They're did Mohammed,
you need to get camp.
When I was at that party at for a brief
second,
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that might be a bomb here is that many
people were threatening their lives.
They really were worried about that.
The people were threatening their lives
because they were making fun of
Mohammed.
What they saying that the time square
guy,
it was something the time square guy
sounds like he's retarded.
You know,
we talked to people that know bombs and
understand construction of bombs and
like this could have never worked.
Like the whole bunch of things work
exactly.
Perfect in order.
He didn't have any experience doing it,
set it up wrong,
you know,
they're like,
this is all wrong.
So He seems like it's just a fucking
retard that they had over there.
Disenfranchise God,
losing his house,
you know,
that kind of a guy and you know,
just wants something to connect
themselves to something significant.
So he decides he's going to be a martyr
and you know,
like when they came up to on the plane
he asked them if they were FBI or CIA.
He asked them what they were in New
York,
priests,
New York police or CIA or FBI.
What are you?
He wanted to know.
He want to know who is getting arrested
bias.
If you wanted to get fucking caught,
here's a dumb ass.
So I think there are groups out there
that are trying to do fucked up shit to
Americans for sure.
There definitely are.
But the thing is the dudes who are
joining these things,
they're fucking mess,
man.
Yeah,
they're idiots.
They're,
they're either idiots or they're all
fucked up or nobody's signing up to do
this shit.
If they got it all together,
you know,
the key to making the world safe is not
killing all the fucked up people.
It's making sure that people coming up,
get it together,
do your best to make sure there's plenty
of cool people do your best to make sure
the kids are raised correctly,
that you just set up good schools and
community centers and do things to try
to enhance the lives of children,
to make them grow up to be more positive
people.
That's the only way to fix this.
How are you going to do that when they
just keep pulling money out of
education?
I mean it's like this,
you know,
there's not enough incentive to them.
They're rich,
rich people put their kids in private
schools.
So they look at,
you know,
the situation like this other people's
problem,
fuck them,
you know,
but it's your problem to manage those
kids grow up and they're disenfranchised
and fucking dangerous,
you know,
if your children have to come in contact
with you now if you go to like places
like Australia,
Canada,
where it's like one group of people,
they seem to be more like a group.
Do you know what I'm saying?
That working together and I love the
diversity of America,
but I wonder if that plays in,
you know,
it's Kinda what I was talking to you on
the phone.
Like when you send it like all the
savages and all that stuff.
Seminar on the way over here,
we were talking about why America,
we were talking about how great Canada
is.
Every time we go up to Canada,
which I just got back,
I was just,
uh,
this weekend I was in a three stops can.
I was in grand prairie.
I was in saskatoon and then I was in
saskatoon.
Grandparent in Winnipeg had a great
fucking time.
Man,
shows are so much fun.
I can love Canada.
I love.
Awesome up there man.
Montreal was awesome.
It's just like there's something about
these people that are,
they're so nice.
It's such a great,
like there's so much like on a,
on the whole somewhat friendlier and,
and in more relaxed than Americans.
Look in their eyes.
You don't see darkness.
You see rainbows,
Douche bags.
You mean there's Douche bags everywhere.
You know,
I had a lot of douchebags in Winnipeg,
a lot of hecklers,
but they're just drunk and retarded.
That's part of life.
Whatever you.
Whatever you did just made the static
come back.
I just moved.
We got a rinky dink system here,
son.
Yeah.
Okay.
I shut my mic off and it's doing it man.
So can't be uh,
so uh,
try to try to figure out what this is.
It's,
it's something over there because I was
fine.
And then you move that stand out as a
stand,
touching a metal.
Try to get comfortable liquid.
It's almost near the end anyway.
Yeah.
But wait a minute,
we can't just keep talking like this
bro.
We started it four slash 15.
We got 15 more minutes.
Don't turn my volume down.
I'm just saying can hear my that twice.
Don't be fucking with them.
You sign it.
Somebody should.
I do.
Should I unplug and replug unplugging.
Implement.
What to do,
Brian.
There's nothing over there.
It's nothing over there.
Don't touch anything over there.
No,
no,
no.
Don't.
I don't know.
Yeah.
It's something over in that mic stand or
your mic.
Because the only thing you did is you
touched the mic.
Stand it.
Turn back those move.
I'll just move.
It's like some kind of done that
rinky dink.
Fucking bullshit.
If I was listening to this on an ipad.
Okay.
Be pissed right now.
Come on.
We gotta fix it.
Take,
take.
Take the mick out of the Stan.
Turn off the mic so you don't blow
everyone's ears.
I'll unplug it and hit the mic.
Stand on the ground.
Not too hard or know that the Michael
Stopped.
No,
because it's unplugged.
You're unplugged it.
So now I'll take that mic though and hit
it on the ground.
Tap It on the ground.
See?
It's bad.
It's the mic.
Uh,
why?
Why would a tap that?
No,
no,
no.
The mic.
You know what?
I mean like if it's a loose connection
or something,
so it's like blowing into the Nintendo
disc control.
Okay.
You know,
I believe it's something to do with that
Mike or the cable that the link is.
Damn it.
How's it connecting brand?
It's just gone right here.
I've heard there.
I did already.
That
what you put me in another whole pulling
out of the hole over there.
It's
not that.
It's.
It has something to do with.
Oh wait,
now there's just no sound.
Is that one one?
There we go.
No,
no.
Sound crackle.
Say it's something on
that side where the mic is.
Okay.
Let's ignore it because knowing is for
listening to this shit.
These fucking faggots just talked about
the sound buzz for 30 seconds and I
think they can hear it.
Only we can hear it because you're that
much because the compression three years
during probably blocks out that that had
with the itunes.
People are gonna.
Hear this shit up.
I'll try to fix it.
Sorry folks.
Very interesting.
Well you were talking about savages.
Yeah.
We were talking about.
This is what Sam triple and I were
talking about on the way over here.
We were talking about why is America so
aggressive?
And we're saying,
well you think about it,
just the people that came to America are
the people that were so fed up with
Europe.
There were so ambitious that they got on
a fucking boat and sailed across oceans
to get over here.
They put themselves through serious,
the most aggressive of the aggressive
and once they got here,
you know,
they were desperado and a lot of them
got here during the depression or before
the depression.
You know,
a lot of them got here back then and
those fucking people do.
The people grew up in the depression,
you know,
they had a fuck.
They were fucking hard people,
man.
Those were hard,
hard times.
You hear stories about soup lines and
whole families being outside and you
know,
I mean you see some of the photos from
the,
from the depression era.
That was scary,
scary shit for people.
So those people grew up hard and they
grew up aggressive and those are the
ones that stayed and they had kids.
And then they had kids and that fucking
aggressive,
aggressive attitude of survival.
It's still still there.
You know.
And then that's one of the reasons why
we've talked about this before about
California so weird is because all the
people that were dissatisfied with the
east coast,
they're all slowly made their way
further and further and further and
further west.
And you mix them with people just want
fame and they know that the most
aggressive be aggressive.
La has got to be the freakiest fucking
place to live ever.
I think it's gotta be like Hollywood
Wall Street and then Washington dc
because you just see the um,
did you see the,
the Laker game thing,
but they were lighting.
The car's on fire after it was over.
Yeah.
They're so angry about that.
And it wasn't even like a cop car or a
government car.
It was a fucking cab.
And you know what I'm saying?
I'm not going to go there.
Nevermind.
Go.
Where am I?
Look,
there's your fucking retarded.
It doesn't matter what ethnicity they
are from anybody who does.
That's an idiot.
And like I said before,
why are they idiots?
Why didn't?
Because they were raised by idiots for
sure.
They're not doing that because that's
human nature to do it because they're
there.
They're born into a fucked up situation
with a ton of struggle by a bunch of
people that can't cope and doesn't,
don't balance things.
Right.
And you know,
born into poverty.
Alot of them born into,
you know,
immigration situations.
There's a lot of fucking stripe.
You're uh,
you're raising kids right now.
Uh,
do you feel like raising kids is almost
like raising a wild animal almost where
you have to like teach them,
you have to almost house trained them
and all that.
So I know you don't want to talk about
your children's not specific like that.
It's much more different.
It's like an alien.
So like something that doesn't even know
this world,
you know,
wild animal has their own instincts and
you have to kind of tone them down.
And I've had wild cats before.
I would feral cats that were raised
outside or they were born outside and
they're wild man,
feral
cats.
Even when you get.
I got mine when he was a kitten,
he was only like two months old.
He was maybe three months old at the
most,
but he was wild as fuck.
I mean wild like hissing at you and
fucking leaping,
clawing the walls and Mon.
I first got them.
I'm a friend of mine that I went to high
school with.
She had a bunch of them in her apartment
was like,
there was a parking lot area and this
female federal Canada at a bunch of
kittens.
So she decIded she was gonna catch the
kittens and give them two houses and she
gave one of them to me and so I took
this fucking cat.
This cat was crazy dude.
I mean I'd never seen anything like it
ever in my life,
but I had a couple of days off work so I
decided I'm going to have to get this
cat delight me.
I've got this cat is going to live in my
house.
I'm gonna have to get this cat to be
chill with me.
So I put one of my bedrooms.
I put a bed in it that I don't normally
sleep in and I put some cat food in
there and some water and I just slept in
there,
read books for two days and wrote
material and hung out with this little
cat until he became my friend,
but dude,
it was crazy.
I'd pick him up.
He would start purring and then I would
put them down as soon as I put them
down,
go fucking crazy and run away from me
and fucking tried to climb up the walls.
It was like when I would pick them up,
the warmth and the comfort in the fact
that I was giving him affection,
a keanu he could relax,
that I was going to do good things,
but as soon as I put them down,
it's was like immediate terror,
so it's nothing or nothing like raising
a wild animal.
It'S like raising something that doesn't
exist and all of a sudden it gets
brought forth into this dimension with a
completely clean slate.
They have no knowledge of what's going
on.
They have certain tendencies,
tendencies towards being needy or
aggressive or tendencies towards being
relaxed and they,
their personality is definitely very and
whether or not that's genetic,
whether or not that's just when they
were born,
you know,
what was going on,
with my wife's body,
what was going on with her diet,
but what's going on with their genetics
was going on with,
you know,
the fucking solar system,
who the fuck knows what influences
behavior,
whether astrology is really not.
And then from there you just get this
blank slate and you got to raise this
blank slate.
But it's really,
it doesn't seem like the community,
like,
you know,
like people think of it as like this
burden,
like,
oh gotta raise this kid.
I used to always think that's probably
what it was like that you have kids.
Like god becomes a burden.
Gotta take care of the kids,
but it doesn't seem like that to me.
To me it seems it's fucking awesome.
It's like you're raising this new little
loving creature,
you know,
this little,
little,
little awesome person that you love so
much,
man.
Like you want to do it like you want to
be with them.
You never.
It doesn't feel like a burden to me,
man.
It feels like a lot of fun.
I mean sometimes it requires a lot of
attention.
It's tough to get things done,
but it's fun.
But it was also.
I'm having a I,
you know,
I had a baby when I was 40.
I didn't have a baby when I was 20 and
broken,
fucked up and confused and trying to
make my way in the world.
I had a baby when I was already relaxed,
you know,
I had a baby when are already had like a
good healthy view of the world.
You know?
I just recently got baby fever.
I think it's the second one that got me.
I'm just like,
you know what?
I'm done.
I don't need to be hanging out at a
comedy club at two in the morning.
I don't need to go to a bar and rave
with my glow sticks when you need to do
it,
you know,
I just,
I feel like I just want to sit at home
and be happy.
And
will you love pets?
You love pets man.
If you love cats and dogs,
I know you do.
You would love a human being.
I think that would make great pets will
make the world would be so muCh better
if more cool people had kids,
you know,
we will.
We would figure out a way to,
you know,
to raise human beings and have like
generations that were really nice and
friendly to each other.
The problem was just too much
inequality,
too much inequality in the way children
are raised as well.
Too much,
too many situations where people are
like looking at people that have things
on tv and go,
why not me?
Or they'd have things in the world that
they don't have and why not me?
What the fuck?
And this too much anger and you know,
I mean,
and that makes her competition in
certain in some ways.
You know,
you See things that other people have
you wish and wish you had and it forces
you to work harder,
but it's also a developed a lot of
stress.
There's a lot of.
Yeah,
every time I think about it then I think
about like,
oh wait,
when she's like,
fucking 14,
12,
11,
do that.
We know how creepy they are.
Think about some guys that we've,
we've come across in our lives and how
fucking nutty there are.
Especially should fear.
No really hate women.
You know,
I,
I've known dudes that really have issues
with women and when women would turn
them down they would yell at them and
shit like that.
And it's really embarrassing and creepy
to be around.
And you know,
you can think,
man,
that could be your daughter.
That could be sam trip,
lee's daughter.
And some guy's yelling at her calling
her a fucking cunt lesbian,
you know,
because she doesn't want his drink.
No thank you.
Yeah,
you fucking cunt.
Lesbian dude.
How many of those guys are out there?
You know what's worse is walking through
vegas like saturday night and just
seeing like at hard rock and seeing like
fucking like just two girls walking
through this maze of fucking drunk
douchebags vegas guys.
And it is sad.
They're like attacked lesbian.
Yeah.
Girls go to lesbian,
asm,
I mean just total speculation.
But I've met girls that go both ways and
sometimes there'll be like lesbians for
like a year.
So it's just,
they get old deed on douche bags.
They just want some kindness in their
life.
And so they just said,
let's just,
I'll be your girlfriend for you.
I'll be flowery.
Eddie's a eddie dated a chick that uh,
she,
she moved somewhere and became a
lesbian.
Yeah.
Like,
you know,
he was dating her and they broke up and
she did it,
a bunch of different dudes and this and
that and blah blah blah.
And then she just decided to take some
time off from dick
fucking scissor for a bit dated.
I hooked up with this chick and right
before we had sex for the fIrst time,
she's like,
I just need to let you know that for the
last five years I've been living as a
lesbian.
Wow.
I'm like,
oh man.
Like I need this kind of pressure.
When I'm like jackie robinson,
man,
I like,
I get one shot and if I don't take care
of business,
nobody gets his dick.
I'm sure.
Was a good shoT.
So it was awesome,
wasn't it?
Oh,
fucking loved it.
she wanted me to crying and she really
wants you to choke her.
Yeah,
I don't like that shit.
She wanted you to choke her and she was
a lesbian.
She wanted the full mail experience,
bro.
You aren't bringing heat.
She's crazy.
I crazy.
It was a good though.
Crazy good.
Yeah.
I like crazy chicks.
Did I ever tell you about like women who
were a little bit cross?
I too.
I,
I don't know why I had a girl that a
little bit and that's another,
another connection.
Like I talked about the foot fetish
thing.
I had a girl that I dated when I was 22
and 21 actually,
and she was older than me.
She was really kind of sexy and she had
a wonky eye and that wonky I've like had
like a thing about wonky eyes and so it
was just a little one.
She's going to try harder.
Brian,
you don't understand.
She's aware that wonky eye and she's
just going to give a little bit more
zest into the kiss.
I just met this asian chick awhile ago
and she had the greatest body and a
little bit cross.
I might.
it's really hot.
Yeah,
I went.
I agree.
I once dated this girl,
I don't know if I'd said this or not on
the podcast,
but I once dated this girl that every
time she would have an orgasm she would
have like a full on seizure and fly off
and hit bookshelves and knocked
bookshelves down and stuff like that and
ever since then I've been hoping that I
get to find another girl like that
because you don't understand how fucking
amazing night is like you were about to.
You're having sex,
you're both to come and then she comes
and she's just flyIng like a flopping
fish all over the place and it's just
like,
well,
should just putting on a show.
No hurt herself doing it.
Like I fucked her.
Make sure she's not just retarded.
No,
no,
no.
To think this is a girl.
I mean she loves.
She loves sex so much.
We did this move like we,
it was when we used to work at this
mexican place and we did this move
called the don pablo.
That's the place we used to work at don
pablos and it was where we did buck to,
but you know,
take my dick and rapid between my legs
and then pull,
hold her legs.
I saw that in a peter north video.
Is that a real video?
I don't even know if that was a real
meal,
but we used to call it the dom pop girls
sucking it that way.
That's what it was at it backwards.
So yeah,
like we're on top and I'm holding her
legs,
pushing the deq in while my dick's,
between my legs going through her from
behind.
How dogs fuck is it
backwards?
Dogs fucked doggystyle they get caught
when they get stuck and they try to step
off.
You know what it's like.
It's like when you're Inside of dudes
guard and he goes for a leg lock and
then you have to step over backwards and
then you get into donkey guard.
Yeah.
But so anyways,
It was weird because it was just a
freak.
She saw she would fucking come and like
the that it would take a minute maybe of
her just sitting there going like,
like screens.
No,
while she's shaking like consultants get
annoying after a while when I was doing
it,
but now it kind of like a fed.
It's like I want it,
I want to do that again.
After a while we like,
will you just shut the fuck up?
I just got like water while she was
doing.
I just like walk up and make sure she
didn't hit her.
I used to date a mexican girl.
Ucl.
Racial slurs at me in bed for real.
Yeah,
it was really hot.
Wow.
I don't know why.
I just really like would be kind of high
racial slurs.
Like what would she say?
Everything.
Like what you might bitch motherfucker.
She dropped the inbox.
I'm really well.
How would she use it?
Say what she's saying.
What the fuck?
This is the podcast one.
There's thousands listening to this
right now.
Tell us what the fuck she would say to
just be like,
fuck me.
Fuck me nigger.
Man.
It's not you saying it.
You know,
but we all know.
We all know what triply this is sad to
me.
Why?
Because you're supposed to say It man.
But tell me what this bitch was saying.
She gonna drop bombs.
Dude.
That's great.
Do you get to make your dick look a
little harder?
Cruisy pitch?
Yeah.
I liked it.
Fucking crazy pitch.
I like it when girls talk.
I did.
I love.
I want to get offended when I have like,
I want her to say offensive shit.
Wow.
I like that.
Hate that quiet shit where there's.
But see I don't like saying shit unless
they are.
So if they're not then I don't say
anything.
I tried to make no noise at all,
but that's awful.
No noise at all.
I'm just like,
oh,
you know,
I'm not doing anything like that.
That sounds like nelson reilly.
Oh,
Charles Nelson reilly is exodus.
terrific.
This was awesome.
Yeah.
You don't make noise,
man.
No,
I try not to get caught out on it.
Sometimes you get called out on it.
Yeah.
I get called out on.
It was so quiet and I'm like quiet girl
who would just explode down there?
Oh,
me too.
Oh yeah.
Love question.
You could always tell when she warm.
It's so great.
you oversee it?
Spray out?
No,
I never really wanted to see it.
I just felt it felt it one time.
God let us hold on to a girl that did
that.
He goes,
but it was inconsistent.
One day be lIke fucking mint juleps the
next day.
Be like gatorade.
I don't know what to fucking expect.
It was still confusing.
It always collected my belly button and
then I used to just lay there after sex
and like flick my finger in my belly
button.
Gross for me.
The fuck out.
Weird cock sucker.
I want some chicken in the back of a
phantom.
You boldly chicken the back of a car
like a rolls royce.
Oh shit.
Yeah,
dude,
I did this gig in this.
I was working with this guy.
Bang some rich guy's wife.
No,
I just.
This chick was running,
running with us and she just,
I'm sitting in the back of car.
She just all over me and then like
everyone leaves car just hanging out and
I just start nailing her in the back and
I'm just instead of answering next time,
just go like this and they continue to
store.
Just ignoring what the fuck you're
saying.
by the way,
this podcast is sponsored by fleshlight?
Yeah,
by the end.
We have to say that at the end,
how much is a phantom cost?
Rose was a half a
million bucks or something.
Dude.
It was real deal shit.
That's like one of those ultimate
philosophy things like I'm sure it's
cool to like drive around in must feel
like really sturdy.
I mean they're like really,
really well made,
but that'S just like an ultimate.
Like flossIng moves those.
That's what those cars like,
you could run those into a building and
you won't get hurt.
They're built to like,
yeah,
they're awesomely built,
but it's like also like the people that
want them.
Like that's an extreme statement,
you know what I'm saying?
I think this guy was a limo driver so he
was one of the cars that.
Oh,
okay,
well and still you want to show people
was the shit.
Act forward.
See what I get when I go out for my
limo.
And it was fun.
Just spray and he's like,
please,
please.
And then they had a mercedes.
They're grower to the mercedes.
So we went over to the mercedes and
finish what we were doing because she is
splattering all over your seats.
Oh yeah.
He didn't want us to ruin his.
oh wow.
That's great.
She a sprayer.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Over the imagine if the back of his
fucking beautiful car to smell like
pussy,
just dirty,
stinky pussy everywhere.
I missed it.
She loved it and asked him.
Oh,
ditching.
Yeah.
You ever meet the chicks who love it in
the ass?
They're pretending to love it in the
ass.
Never met somebody that loved girls that
say they love it.
They love it in there.
I've heard girls yell it out at a comedy
club.
Some people,
it just depends how like some people
have whatever that that sensitive ass
hole where it feels like a a.
I can have orgasms from it.
That's how much how sensItive it is and
other girls don't have that vein or
whatever that goes through the side of
it.
That's a doctor talking right now.
Just dr red,
that's ghetto daca.
Yeah,
you cut that vein is all about sex.
You get that?
Dalai lama's antibodies sucks.
So he's anti gay sex.
I guess he's not even.
He's anti blowjob too,
so he is the anti gay sex.
Most of the sexual only be used for
procreation.
Oral and anal is sexual
indiscretion.
I mean most of the year,
like in christianity,
all the taboo.
Sex is our.
Don't create more christians,
but who support?
Supportive.
Why more gay people in the dalai lama,
the dalai lama is essentially saying
that what they're doIng is they're doing
is unnatural and is a.
Is not what you should be pursuing.
You should only be pursuing pursuing
sex.
that creates babies.
That's literally what he's saying.
That's.
He probably doesn't get laid that much
at all.
How about ever me?
Maybe he gets laid occasionally.
I don't know.
We don't know.
Maybe.
fuck Sharon Stone and flashlights.
Fleshlight fleshlight.
Send them an avatar.
One.
We need to figure out a way to get
avatar on board with this.
By the way.
They have clear ones.
I was like,
oh man.
That's like fucking wonder woman when
she's in the.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
totally miserable jet.
Just look down and you see lIttle wonder
woman interject.
I like the idea of a clear one though,
man,
because there's something serial killer
about the whole rubber pussy that's the
same car as an actual pussy.
Have you ever seen those dolls?
They're like life real dolls.
Yeah.
I thought about getting a gay one for
jujitsu.
I was already.
That'd be the perfect thing to practice
on because it's just like a real dude
because I have a.
But then I thought,
how do you explain that away?
I got fake jujitsu dummies in my garage
that I practice on,
like if I can't get to class and I got
some shit I got to work on,
I'll work out on the dummy,
go over moves on a dummy because it's
like it's above a dump.
They make them for gracie jujitsu,
but it's not as accurate as like a real
doll.
I bought a real dog would work better,
but you know what,
you should just get you have cast just
to get it to put in your closet and look
at it all.
I would want to dude.
Oh,
skin tone.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
that's.
I think the sign was tough.
I heard drew carey at eight real dose.
Really a shoot.
Carrie's got so much money,
man.
Dude,
how great is that gig?
He's such a nice guy too,
man.
True.
Karen is like one of the nicest guys I
think I've ever run across.
Always friendly,
always a big smile on his face.
I've never even heard of it being a
dick,
you know,
just always like a fun guy to be around.
Loves comedy,
gives advice to comics.
He was given advice to some fucking new
comic at the improv the other day,
not the other day.
It was like maybe a couple months ago,
but drew was there and there was some
new comic there and we were all talking
and the new comic asks a question and
drew carey just gave them all sorts of
information.
Just write 30 jokes a day.
Just sit down and force yourself to
write.
Get up every time you can record your
act.
he was like giving them all this great
fucking advice jokes.
It's like if you do that,
if you.
If you do that,
if you really dedicate yourself,
you're going to have some gems.
You're gonna come up with some gems.
You force yourself to write something,
you know,
just sit down and write a bunch of shit
like that.
He's so right.
He's fucking great advice,
but the fact that he took the time to do
that to some kids from Ohio,
Ohio guy,
that's where columbus,
Ohio does have a lot of nice people.
There are a lot of canadians in a way,
a little less,
little less cool.
Chicks are great.
I like Ohio tick's mid west.
They've always been very nice to from
stock.
I do.
I like thick chicks.
I like amazon's.
That's why I loved Australia.
Just amazon chicks,
strong women.
I saw.
I read that on your twitter,
right?
They're all amazons and pregnant.
Those are my two favorite things.
Australia is a pretty awesome fucking
country man.
There's no religious guilt out there.
You can do.
I was doing.
Jesus jokes are fucking great man.
They're friendly as shit too.
I got to talk slow though to like you
have a really thick accent.
I could do their accent is pretty bad
ass.
Their accent just sounds party because
like if you had token like that might,
you know like that's not like a guy who
takes himself too seriously.
That's the guy who's going to throw you
another beer and then I was in sydney.
It's pretty expensive over there,
man.
A little bit.
Cindy's the shit though.
Todd's fucking.
They're removed from everybody,
man.
it's hard to get shit over there.
Our driver was telling us how much cars
are there.
They're like real expensive because they
got to ship them from other places they
have like their own australian cars.
You don't recognize like,
what the fuck is that some weird alien
car and shit.
You know,
they're like completely removed from the
rest of the world.
They're fucking far away.
And the crazy thing is that was a prison
colony for england in england is fucking
boring as shit.
Rainy weather all fucked up.
Australia is beautiful and that's a
prison colony and there.
So.
Cool.
How the fuck did that happen?
I don't know man.
By the best time.
How long were you there for?
Two and a half weeks.
Yeah,
Australia is the shit,
man.
Had a good.
were you on a this week man?
I'm doing my uh,
naughty show to my own notes,
right?
That's right.
Sam.
Triple 8:00
tomorrow night are you should fear will
be guests who do,
doing some sort of guest appearance.
Rowdy roddy motherfucking piper's going
to be there.
Is that he's gonna make an appearance.
He's sam.
How do people keep up with you?
So they know about the future,
the future naughty shows and all this
shit.
I already comedy show on twitter.
I'm on twitter,
a sam aaa and if on ustream that's
easier,
just as good as the naughty comedy
show.com
for that actual thing.
Trying to spell tripoli,
the naughty comedy show.com.
Sam triple.com.
Please note that I have in the us,
it sounds us national air humping
championships to really.
Yeah,
it's going to be big if you,
uh,
seen sam sam's been on the road with me
a bunch of times before we did a toronto
together.
We did a bunch of gigs up and sat down
and we did sacramento together and we're
doing the house of blues together on
July 2nd,
tripoli in vegas.
The big brock lesnar shankar when I
decided the white gorilla festival.
Uh,
we're going to have a good fucking time,
man.
So a sam tripoli tomorrow night at the
melrose improv.
Ten pm show,
8:00
PM,
show eight shows.
And I,
Dr.
Mann and joanne angels ain't got it.
He's got a bunch of very attractive
young ladies will fuck for a living.
And then,
um,
I will be this weekend at the irvine
improv,
friday,
saturday and sunday with ari.
Fear and joey coco diaz.
Oh,
snap.
Full death squat appearance.
Brian's gonna.
Be there.
Video taping.
So if you want to kiss brian,
he's ready.
Yes.
Ready?
Because people.
Yes.
Because anybody,
boy,
gIrl,
whatever.
No,
no.
Okay.
No flashlights.com.
Go to joe's website.
Click on the link at 15 percent off.
They are awesome.
And we both love them.
You know,
we fucked me up and if anyone from
flashlights listening get us more.
We need chris crystal.
I emailed him yesterday to tell him that
the flashlight has made it into my act.
Now there's like I have a whole chunk on
the flashlight and how the chunks.
I think that's the best way to do
comedy.
It's the,
you know,
the guy who I really emulated.
Where I learned that from was richard,
jenny,
because richard,
jenny would write and he would write the
shit out of a subject.
Man.
I remember I was always impressed when I
would go to see him that this guy,
like when a guy has just one thing on a
subject,
he brings up a subject,
he has a thing on it,
and then he moves onto the next subject.
I always feel like,
well,
you just started toucHing on the
subject.
You sure that that's all the angles that
are in that subject.
I don't,
I don't feel like I got enough out of
that experience,
but when I would go see richard,
jenny,
that guy would like write these big long
word,
but right when he thought he was done
with it,
he would hit you with more shit with it
and it made it funnier and funnier.
More ridiculous as it
got along.
So I learned how to do that from him
too.
Well,
you do chunks to men.
Electronic store guys do chunks,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of guys from there,
we have similar styles.
You know,
we'd go loose.
It's not like verbatim same way every
night because that place is like a chaos
place.
Yeah.
You can't go up there and do a
monologue.
Nobody wants to hear that shit,
you know,
you're going to have to interact with
people at some point.
That's why hey,
showcase.
And I think showcasing for something Is
just so not natural,
like seven minutes.
Yeah.
And just go up there and a to z and it's
just like,
that's not what I do.
It's like I like to be in the moment,
talk about what's going on.
And it's funny because kennison who was
one of my favorite comics and I think
one of yours as well always had that
problem,
you know,
and it's a comedy store guy as well.
he always had the problem where he said,
it takes me 10 minutes to get cooking.
I don't want to do like seven minutes.
He got a problem and he didn't want to
do.
When the rodney dangerfield specialist
on,
he was like,
wow,
you know,
10 minutes.
This isn't a lot of time.
Like he had a concern about that,
you know,
I think we both have that style that
comes from the chaos of that fuckIng
crazy comedy store
I did,
man.
When I walk up on stage,
I just,
it takes me a little longer than
everybody else.
You know,
when there's people who walk up on stage
and they have a certain look,
you kind of know what they're going to
talk about.
So people like our rem board,
do you know what I'm saying?
Like john gibberella goes up with a hat
and he looks like one of the guys from
south park and talks like this,
you know,
and it's like he's already kind of like
already in.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's about ideas goes up.
He's hilarious rail fuck cock suckers.
What are you looking at?
What's going on here?
It always takes me like a couple
minutes.
I'm fine with that now,
but when I first started I was always
get very,
like,
panicky and then it says that's your set
off in a bad direction,
but you have this casual like you're,
your act is like,
you know,
I mean,
sam's one of the funniest guys I've
worked with,
he's really hilarious.
If you haven't seen him do stand up
before his.
Have you seen him in toronto?
You know,
if you've seen them in any of the places
we went to,
you know,
um,
but you know,
his act is,
you got,
you don't have any fat in your ax,
you're not trying too hard a bunch of
bits.
You're not doing a bunch of shit.
That's,
you know,
like in the beginning of your career,
like everybody,
like I had it.
Everybody has it.
You have a bunch of bits that you know
you have in there just because they're
in there,
you should have probably cut them out,
you cut all that shit out,
you know,
your shit is all like what you think is
funny and how you look at things.
So when you go up there,
there's no you don't like,
like try to fake them out right away and
get them,
get them going.
You just get into your shit.
You know,
it take your time,
you know,
it takes a few minutes.
But once you get that rhythm experience.
I love that though.
I love watching the guy do that man.
I love watching the guy like set up his
shit and get into it slowly.
I really get uncomfortable when I see
someone like panicking,
you know,
when I see someone trying to hard or,
or saying a bunch of shit that's not
real,
you know,
or trying to force things don't eat,
you'll feel that,
you know,
man,
I'll be honest with you dude.
Like,
you know,
I love working with you joe,
because you're literally the probably
the only person that I can just do any
joke I want unleash,
just throw it out there and just go for
blood and you just fucking just grabbed
the wave and just go,
you know,
and follow up.
I mean I've literally gone on roads with
people and had to pull punches,
you know,
and I understand because
very similar though,
your,
your sense of humor,
my sense of humor,
a very similar so that when you're on
stage and you're killing,
you know,
I'm laughing my ass off.
So when I go on stage I'm in a good
mood.
Like I'm laughing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I feel like,
wow,
it was a fun fucking show.
This is fun and I just carry it on.
They get rocked.
If you don't have that kind of act
though,
if you have the kind of act that's like
really,
you know,
like a monologue act or someone who's
like more sedated.
It doesn't talk about controversial
subjects.
The problem is once the cat's out of the
bag,
you know,
like once you start talking about wild
shit,
when you're up there,
the guy after you,
it's going to be really hard for him to
be like sedate.
It's going to be really hard for him to
be like middle America,
you know,
fucking now ready for letterman.
You know what I mean?
There was a time when I used to struggle
at their.
John kept barolo because he was very
mainstream,
lovable,
and I go up there with my weird stuff
and you feel it,
right?
The.
Yeah.
And it's just like,
whoa.
Hey,
whoa,
whoa.
We're just,
you know,
we've been.
We like ice cream.
Do you know what I'm saying?
You can't.
You can't convert them yet.
That's what it is.
You don't know how to convert them yet,
you know,
or you didn't at the time.
Rather.
I used to feel that way about age agent
mall.
Ha.
Jamal was joey diaz is kryptonite for a
long time ago.
Modular lego.
That's a funny dude.
He's one of those guys.
There's a few guys where I go.
This doesn't make any sense.
How is this guy?
Not a huge household.
I'm with you dude.
Squeaky clean.
Hilarious,
brilliant timing.
Great writing.
fucking super nice guy.
Super nice friendly guy and here it is.
You know,
we knew him from the store.
From what?
Ten years ago.
Here he is.
He's not famous,
you know,
that's crazy to me.
I mean do people are like,
oh ha.
Jamal killed last time.
I was like,
tell me when he doesn't kill.
That's why.
Because he murders room
steward.
He's.
He was when we knew him too,
when he was at the store a lot.
Like in the early two thousands.
He was an executioner.
Brow.
He would go up and we did a lot of the
same material,
but he would go up and do 15 minutes of
thunder sun and it will be squeaky clean
and perfectly timed out and you know,
you would feel like,
especially if you have that lag of
loose,
you know,
dirty style where you're talking shit on
stage,
you'd feel like unprepared when you're
gone,
you know,
because it's such a totally different
style of comedy.
Funny man.
Yeah.
You always wonder that.
You know,
there's a lot of guys like that.
Man.
I always talk about reggie mcfadden
regimen fat and back in New York in the
nineties I knew reggie mcfadden like 93,
94.
He was a destroyer dude.
He would go up squeaky clean,
totally digestible for tv and he would
just fucking crush.
He was a monster man and for whatever
reason it just never connected.
I know he got on in living color like I
think unlike the last season or one of
the last seasons,
you know,
and he did a little bit on that,
but for whatever reason it never took
off.
When I saw him,
I was like 22 or something like that.
When I first saw him,
I was like,
whoa,
this guy is going to be a fucking star.
I'm like,
this guy is so charismatic.
His act was clean.
I wanted to like,
um,
like he would be on stage.
I was like,
I was learning from watching him
perform.
Definitely,
you know,
there's guys that you've seen and you
go,
man,
I learned something watching that guy,
I need to be more,
have more fun with this or I,
I enjoyed that part about his act,
you know?
Um,
what,
uh,
how come I'm like that in my real life,
but I'm not like that on stage.
I needed to learn how to be myself on
stage.
Like he is,
you know,
he was one of those dudes,
man,
he just fucking crushed,
crushed.
You would just be humbled.
Like,
whoa,
that guy's good.
And then for whatever reason,
man,
I just never fucking clicked.
It never clicked.
You know,
you never see him headlining these big
shows that you hear about at these
theaters and shit like that.
I don't even know where he is anymore.
I don't know where he is.
Either used to do poppins and I was
like,
I don't know why this guy is popping and
he's not really celebrity.
It was always really funny,
but no,
I haven't seen him at the comedy store
in years.
Yeah.
He,
you do pop ins.
He had a little bit going on back in.
Know he did a movie like a little while
ago.
Very funny though,
man.
Steve white.
There's another one.
Steve white is fucking hilarious.
Dude.
That guy's one of the most confusing
guys to me.
That and I know he made a ton of money
off real estate.
He became like some crazy fucking real
estate investor and I think he does like
seminars now.
He has a radio show for awhile there in
vegas.
Did he do that?
I was funny as shit.
He's another guy.
That guy should have been a giant.
Should've been fucking headlining
everywhere over the world.
We're talking about a bunch of people
that no one knows about.
We're talking about comedy,
but there's also something about what we
knew about these people,
man.
Yeah,
but they don't have to know we're
talking about,
but I'm listening to the little comics
that we knew that were really funny and
we're describing.
I know a lot of people asking like,
how do we know these people?
Why would we care about this?
Who are these people?
Stop reading that man.
Don't bring that up man.
Hours,
20 minutes.
Don't bring up negative shit.
You're bringing up negative shit that
these people are saying that they're not
into it.
We're talking about comedy and what's
our history and to us it's interesting.
People that are into comedy,
it's going to be.
You're also putting on a show right now.
Yeah,
bro.
I know what I'm doing,
man.
Stop this.
Don't fucking tell me what to talk
about.
I'm fascinated by this.
You're not helping.
It's not helping bring it up.
Negative shit.
It's not helping.
It's interesting to me and I think I
want to give guy credit and I want to
give adrian jamal credit and I want to
talk about all these guys.
They were fucking funny.
Genius guys that helped us when we were
coming up,
you know,
watching all these different guys.
I think that's one of the most Important
things about comedy development is being
around a bunch of other really funny
comedians,
you know,
and,
and like feeding off of each other.
And it's a blessing too because like
being in la,
it's like,
believe it or not,
the comedy level so high,
he's like,
you know,
I go on the road,
even if I'll go down to san diego or
something and you see what they're used
to seeing and they're performing at that
level.
It's like in la,
you know,
I had to either for god knows how many
times they had to follow you at the
comedy store and it's like,
I can't fuck around with that.
You know,
all these other great comics.
LiKe you see what you got to get to and
where are you going to operate at?
And god knows I had to follow a lot of
guys too.
And that's one of the things that mitzi
shore a really helped me and a lot of
other comedians with.
She knew how to schedule guys,
you know,
and she always would talk to me about
it,
you know,
and I told her,
I said,
you know,
you really made me,
uh,
you know,
you really helped my development as a
comedian.
She goes,
I always nowhere and I pull it.
Yeah.
You know,
she will put me over after murderers,
man,
martin lawrence and his prime.
He would go up in the main room and
fucking destroyed.
Dude.
It was back when he had that.
What was that movie that he had the
concert movie of him doing standup,
something run something crazy,
wasn't it you so crazy or something like
that.
I don't know.
Someone was brian.
Anyway,
he,
he used to destroy.
He would level that main room.
Then I would go up and I was nobody and
I wasn't very confident and people,
as soon as they saw me,
they would get up and leave.
But how many times in my life,
dude,
for like the first year is at the store.
Andrew dice clay pretty much bumped me
every night.
I know,
man.
It was brutal.
Dice,
dice.
They were scheduled him before me a
bunch of times or after hammer other a
bunch of times I'd have to go up after
him and I used to listen to his cds or
cassettes rather.
They were cassettes back in the eighties
to one of my favorite moments was
watching him on new year's doing his
nursery rhymes.
Yeah.
See that live when I grew up on that was
like phenomenal.
There was an hbo special that was live
right from philly,
wasn't it?
Or he.
Yeah,
and then I saw them do it in the olr one
time on new years.
I'm like,
wow,
that's pretty damn cool,
man.
Dude.
I remember working with him just being
like standing next to him going,
holy shit,
this is dyce client.
Yep.
You know,
to me it's like right there with
kennison as far as like the
Impressionable comics.
I mean,
you know,
people say he's an asshole.
He just hate comedy and isn't that I
don't care.
To me,
it's funny,
you know,
I'm not looking to,
for him to have the,
you know,
the best philosophy in life and teach me
how to live my life,
but he,
he's made me laugh hard before when I
was a kid and insulting people at the
store.
How many times does he just started
attacking dudes?
oh,
he texts his own fans are awesome dice.
Hey,
fuck you dude.
He's ruthless.
He's ruthless shitting on people he does
not care to.
Yeah.
That,
that comedy store environment growing up
in that crazy fall.
Eddie griffin,
after he did three hours,
I've seen that.
I've seen you follow him.
I saw you follow him at least twice
after he did three hours and the people
were just destroyed by the time it was
over.
They had nothing left in them.
By the time eddie,
eddie would start off doing material and
then two hours in,
he'd be like,
the africans built the pyramids with
sound.
See,
y'all don't understand.
Nine slash 11 happened.
There was gold underneath those twIn
towers.
Subway ran 24 hours a day.
Like you'd like to leave you like,
what the fuck is he saying now?
I don't know what's going on.
I think kat williams just came,
took all this thunder and then,
I don't know man.
Well he had a problem opening up for
certain guys.
He's like,
oh,
but I think it was mike apps.
I think you were open for he.
He was opening for some guys and like
they just weren't.
Maybe it was kat williams.
They were just not into a shit man
because he's got that style that
just shit talk and style,
you know,
he's like suited to.
I think eddie's like at his best when
he's like in like the oh are and it's
like a friday night and they don't
expect them and he goes out,
but he's feeling just perfect.
You've got to just the right amount to
drink and just the right amount of
feeling good and he'll go up there and
fucking slay it.
But do you remember back when he had his
first hbo appearance?
Now he's like a young comedian specials
or something or def jam maybe it was
deaf jam.
Yes,
it was deaf jam.
And he fucking destroyed 80.
Griffin was one of the most fucking
charismatic and powerful standups ever
for like a short period of time you
would go to see like his,
his like hbo performance when he was on
def jam at the time.
But the impact that it happened,
I remember watching it being like,
whoa,
this guy's fucking talented.
Just powerful and dynamic and all this
energy and woo and good man.
It was good fucking material.
But somewhere along the line he just
went crazy.
Yeah.
I don't know what did do three hours and
45 minutes of it was gold.
There was some really funny as shit.
He would say shit.
Sometimes it would make me go.
This guy like in spurts is like one of
the funniest ever.
One of the funniest ever.
Do you ever heard his bit about
Alexander Graham bell is do a bit about
cocaine.
Then Alexander Graham bell invented the
telephone.
He's like,
you gotta be has motherfucker want to
talk to someone who ain't even there.
That's funny.
Shit.
How much coke you got to do before you
like,
I want to talk to some nigga.
Ain't even here.
It's a funny bit,
man.
He had some funny fucking shit,
but it was bursts of it,
you know,
bursts of genius followed by all this
time.
I just think like in la,
like when you're doing like a set psych,
people can only take so much and like
three hours.
Nobody could take three hours of
anybody.
I don't think anybody.
Would you ever want to hear anything you
think about like these chappelle in
these dane cook sets?
What do you guys think about those sets
were dudes do like six,
seven,
trusting.
I hate it.
I think it's the worst idea ever.
I think.
I think less is always more.
I always found it interesting that date
that dane always got like a bad,
you know,
energy from that.
And then for the longest time nobody
cared about dave chappelle.
No one would ever be like fucking
chappelle bummy.
They'd be like,
yeah,
chappelle went up to three hours.
it was awesome.
Well,
he seems now it's kind of changed,
but at the time
time,
like ran up to the chappelle show,
especially after he left,
he was like,
this martyr for comedy.
You know,
because everybody had heard that like
the comedy central suits were fucking
with his show and trying to get him to
stop saying nigger and trying to sell
more advertising and they wanted to kill
them more money.
There's a big $50,000,000
deal and he just went fuck you.
And walked away.
And I think everybody just,
he became the messiah,
you know,
every comic was like,
wow,
that guy's a real fucking comic.
Like he really walked away from $50
million dollars.
Who the fuck walks away from $50,
million dollars?
Who gets in a fucking plane and just
goes to africa?
So for us,
like he embodied everything that a real
comic is supposed to be.
Dude's a genius
comedian.
Hilarious as fuck.
Had the funniest show in the history of
television change.
Did it change the way people thought?
Yeah,
I mean it was that.
I mean like stuff that he did on the
show became part of the lexicon.
I'm rich bitch.
How many people just would yell that
out?
How many people yell out fuck your
couch.
You know how many people would yell out
all that stuff?
That stuff became.
It just,
it just,
it had an impact that nothing else did,
man.
And so when he stepped away from that
and everybody was like,
wow,
he really doesn't give a fuck.
He was mad at him at all.
I always wonder if like,
you killed like the golden goose.
it was all fake.
No,
he can sell so much,
man.
He can do whatever he wants.
I don't think he gives a fuck.
If he wanted to sell out stadiums,
dude,
he could sell out stadiums.
He's not trying.
He's showing up at comedy clubs like
unannounced and shit.
He's showing up and doing guest spots
and shit and going up for a couple of
hours here and there where he's not even
like having people pay to see him.
He's not doing that many real shows.
He's a,
an interesting motherfucker man.
Very interesting.
But I think that's really why everybody
doesn't care that he goes up like we all
want to see him.
You know,
he represents to a lot of comics,
like he's the embodiment of what you're
supposed to be.
He's like the richard pryor of our
generation.
Yeah.
The guy who goes up and everybody wants
to sit and watch them,
you know?
Is he your favorite comic?
Who's your favorite comic?
Uh,
I have,
uh,
david tells one of my favorites.
I just love the way he writes in.
His tags are really good.
I like,
uh,
you stand hope bill burn and you know,
nick swardson I think is really fucking
funny.
His specials,
one of the only specials I like for some
reason I can't watch comedy,
man.
I don't know what it is.
I've been,
I dunno man.
So I'll watch like clumps,
but somehow I got through his whole
entire special laughing my ass off man.
Yeah,
he's really funny dude.
That fucking thing that he does what he
said,
if I was going to commit suicide,
I want everybody to be really confused
after it was over,
like pull out a gun and go who fucking
farted brains out.
That's hilarious.
Shit dude.
And he's goT great stage presence and
delivery.
I was in minneapolis and he was there
too,
is when brock lesnar was fighting and
uh,
it was the night before we did a show at
the fine line music cafe and swarts and
came to the show and he just walked on
stage while I was on stage and he's,
he's like one of those dudes who like,
I love him so much.
He's so fun to be around.
I'm always happy to see him,
like one of the few dudes that would
show up and then just walk on stage.
I just give him the microphone and give
him a hug,
you know what I mean?
like I'd be happy.
It's like a for him it was like,
it was like a cool thing on stage.
He's a great guy,
great guy.
I used to do beecher's madhouse at the
hard rock in vegas and he came out and
party one night and then he just
disappeared.
He showed up the next day and he's like,
I'm like,
where'd you go?
He goes,
you don't want no,
and I'm like,
you know what?
I felt so fun,
dude.
Man,
he's a great guy,
but he's one of those guys like he could
probably do that to you.
He would go onstage and you'd be happy
to see them on stage with you.
Like,
oh yeah man,
but how many guys are like that?
There's so few.
You know,
I don't know anybody who I would be
comfortable going on stage on their
show.
I don'T know anybody who walks up.
He's like,
what the fuck man,
I would never do that with you.
Like if you were doing a show somewhere
and I came to watch,
I would never go on stage and just
assume that we're going to give you the
microphone.
I'd start talking to be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
You don't do enough shows.
Yeah,
come steal my thunder mother fucker.
You happened to jen kirkman.
She's a comic.
Last night she went off on her twitter
because she had a 30 minute spot at the
improv and somebody went on stage.
She didn't say who it was,
jumped on stage and didn't,
but she was going crazy both on the,
the,
you know,
the improv,
the emotion.
But you read her shit,
jen kirkman,
you agreed.
I don't know.
He was a contestant or you worked for
last comic standing,
but she never said she wouldn't say who
it was.
greg giraldo?
no,
no.
It wasn't great.
So how much time did they do?
I liked,
I don't know.
I don't know,
but just to check our twitter.
It's pretty days on that show,
but I like trello.
I looked up to.
That's life man.
You know comics are going to go on
before you and bump you especially.
No one knows.
Who the fuck are you?
I'm so numb to it,
man.
It's amazing how everyone gets so angry.
I am so numb to getting bumped
test,
man.
It's a test for comics.
It's good for you when you're starting
out.
It's not good when you get to a certain
level and people are paying to see you
and somewhat contrary to your point of
view goes on and goes up.
You know like,
like you know what I'm saying?
Agreements.
See story was headlining addison improv
and I'm sitting there in the back office
and all of a sudden I see brad williams
walk and I'm like,
hey brad.
I'm like,
oh fuck him walks fucking carlos mencia.
He fucking does 30 minutes.
I can't even get away from him and
dallas does 30 minutes before me.
Doesn't even ask me like,
doesn't he?
Hey dude,
you mind if I do 30 minutes?
Doesn't even ask.
Just soon as he's doing it.
Does it on purpose?
He did it to put you in place.
I mean,
that's what he did this to.
Everybody goes up there,
right?
I tell him,
I go,
he goes over 30 minutes.
I ain't going onstage.
He gets off at 27 minutes.
He's killing.
And he goes,
thank you guys.
So much.
Place goes nuts.
And they go,
right?
He goes,
are you ready for your next comedian?
And the whole place literally goes like,
someone's got filed this.
This is crazy.
I walked to the stage.
He introduces me.
I'm want to say he doesn't even wait for
me to be to get to the stage.
Literally.
I've never seen anyone do this before.
Runs a full sprint off the stage to the
side,
to his left leaves the stage gmt.
I go up to make you feel uncomfortable.
I get up there.
I got this joke.
I always drop when I fall.
Big name somewhere.
Drop it.
Place goes nuts.
I kill for 45 minutes.
Like the crowd was like,
we can fucking do this.
You know what I'm saying?
Money.
You know,
they didn't know.
They probably.
A lot of them didn't know who you were.
They were just going to see some comedy
and they've maybe heard your name or
something like that,
but he was as national headline of go,
just destroyed.
Oh,
in just trying to bury me.
That's what he loves to do.
he's a sick person,
man.
You know the mark marin podcast was
fascinating.
Listen to it because it was like
listening to a crazy person.
The crazy thing is he bumped marin.
Marin was at the improv once.
He bumped marin for like an hour.
Marin didn't even say anything to them
until the second podcast.
You know,
the first time he didn't bring it up
like,
hey,
why'd you bump me for an hour?
I'll fuck you forget that.
See that whole thing about that video is
man,
it's like he brought that on himself to
new videos.
The craziest thing ever.
That's just flat out positions and
that's where he is where you are.
It's obvious who was on stage for.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
I mean,
you were there before you left and you
came back,
right?
Yes.
So he brought that on self.
I didn't see what the situation of
bullying or anything like that.
That's his mare and being silly marries
a contrarian.
He's always trying to find some fucking
unique angle that other people don't
see.
That's my biggest problem.
So he's still,
he's complained about,
and I love baron,
you can't complain about joke stealing
and then he did a lot of dumb shit.
Not only did they complete,
this is what marin does.
Marin compared it to people being
influenced by people that there are
other people that sound like people,
which is.
I've,
I've been guilty of.
we've all been given.
Yeah,
I think everybody is,
yeah,
when you get influenced by people,
but that's not.
Plagiarism does a huge fucking
difference between that plagiarism.
It's a ridiculous comparison and the
other thing that he said was that I
thought was really kind of fucked up was
like that,
like he made it through comedy,
did everything to comedy and just had a
lot of hard work and he can't wait to
take away the fact that he worked hard.
Like what the fuck are you talking
about?
You're talking about a guy who's
stealing and then he also said that he
thought that the video should have been
released,
that we should have handled this within
the community.
This is all coming from a guy who's got
a fucking podcast.
We're four hours talking about it
sounded like a 10 minute video or
podcast talking about it on more than
one occasion.
It's ridiculous.
Silly marin's fucking karma,
bro.
That's what that was,
man.
Nobody wanted that to happen,
you know?
I didn't know.
I just wanted him to not be there.
I wanted him to not do what he was
doing.
We didn't want to set out to try to
fucking destroy somebody.
It was.
We had a problem we had a deal with,
but how,
how bad was the store?
How many times have you seen people
freak the fuck out?
Because that guy was in the back of the
room.
I don't do.
I did.
The funniest thing about him is like,
he's so easy to follow if like if I
actually did my material,
it's so easy to follow,
but you don't want to do your good shit
because it was in the room.
Right?
So I just go to crowd work and sometimes
it goes great and sometimes it doesn't.
I just,
you know,
that was what was missing from this
whole discussion with the real problem
with having something like that is not
whether or not anyone's free of guilt.
The real problem is what the situation
is.
As someone who is ruining an artistic
environment and creating a bunch of
stress and tension all for their own
personal gain.
And this isn't respected by the other
people that are selling the art form.
The people that are owning the comedy
club,
that people that are like the only
reason why a comedy club is open,
it's not just a place to buy drinks.
It's a place to watch comedians perform
and who you
got someone who's actively victimizing
the other participants in this community
that keeps you alive and you're letting
that person for short term.
I don't get it.
It's just they're not artists.
They're selling art.
They are not artists.
They don't respect it the way an artist
respects,
you know,
and,
and you know,
just things he said on that podcast in
terms of just,
you know,
he sits still.
He acts,
he says he doesn't sit in a room,
he sits in the room texting who you
texting,
your texting yourself.
I mean it's like if you really wanted
people not to hate you anymore,
you would never go in the room when you
weren't performing.
I have this theory dude,
like if if you're a guy who's been doing
comedy over like 10 to 12 years and
you're like watching like open mics,
you're probably,
they're fishing for material
or you could be a really curious person
wants to see the beginnings again and
see horrible failures and see like what
it feels like to watch somebody like
real nervous and uncomfortable to sit
there the whole night and just be.
Who knows,
you know.
I mean,
I'm not saying that anybody watching an
open mic night is definitely a thief,
but suspect there's.
You can get.
You can cherry pick some great ideas
that people don't know how to work in an
open mic night.
Right?
I mean,
how many times you watched an open mic
night not micro go,
wow,
that's a good idea.
He's not doing it right,
but that's a great fucking idea of using
go tell them how to tweak it.
Yeah,
that's a nice thing to do,
man.
I've had people do that to me and it's
really cool when someone comes up to you
like lucy kay was the last one to do
that to me.
He saw my sat and then afterwards he
actually wrote a bunch of shit down and
he gave me a couple of cool ideas.
Cool.
That's another thing.
He's a great guy.
He's,
I think he's the best right now as far
as like,
he's the most prolific,
you know,
he's the patent as well.
Patents and another one who I think is
fucking.
Yeah,
I think penn is very funny.
I,
you know,
I have this whole thing about
alternative comedy and I find it very
funny because like the,
almost like the mount rushmore of
alternative comedy,
which is like,
you know,
pat and sarah silverman,
I'm David Cross and zach alpha nag.
It's like they're funny people.
They have set up,
they have punchline.
There is no alternative to it.
The exact same conversation yesterday
for a long time.
Like what is alternative comedy?
How are these mainstream comedians talk
about mainstream subjects and they do
stand up comedy form.
How is that alternative?
Like it's,
it's so hard to define what alternative
comedy is.
I just think it's,
as far as I can tell,
it's a look now.
It's like you have all five.
Look,
I don't because like I did the vancouver
comedy festival with the vivid video
comedy tour.
It was me two porn stars and nerds.
It was all nerds and I would watch like
their sets and they talk about this shit
I've heard everybody talk about,
but they did it with glasses on and
reading off a notebook.
It's like the closest thing to
alternative comedy might be a.
Is it tim and eric's great show,
good jobs.
Those guys are brilliant,
but they're not going for your normal
like setup,
punch.
ThAt might be alternative kaufman this
like they're brilliant to.
Have you ever seen that video?
they did with that.
I don't even know lord dale.
Did you ever see that one?
No.
That's the greatest one of all time.
That where the grinding and choking they
fuck and it's all psychedelic and crazy
neon jumping in fucking dude.
It's amazing.
humbling,
humbling.
That's like real alternative comedy.
I completely agree with you.
The rest of it is just like.
It's like,
come on,
man,
you're.
You're onstage with notes and that makes
it alternative.
What they've done is they've created an
environment where they can go with w
zero performance.
Yes,
on purpose and they don't like people to
perform,
which is understandable.
Some people like soft music,
you know,
some people like real calm,
soft music,
people like metal,
you know,
it's all.
It's all a choice issue.
I like all sorts.
like I like jeff foxworthy,
mankato crazy,
but I think.
I think he's funny.
Dude is funny bro.
Yes,
I think so.
I could dig alan degeneracy man back in
the day watching her specialty cable
guy.
He's got some great fucking jokes.
I like a wide range of stuff.
Some people get very particular about
the comedy music,
about comedy,
about literature,
about everything.
You know,
it's a lot of shit to enjoy,
man.
It doesn't.
It doesn't have to be exactly your speed
for you to enjoy it.
There's a lot of shit that's good that
doesn't necessarily resonate with how
you would do it,
but still I enjoy it.
The only people that drive me crazy are
the clean nazis.
Especially if they're like the filthiest
people offstage.
Yes.
You're making a business decision.
that's fine.
You make that decision,
But don't get mad at me because I'm me
on stage.
I'm just.
It's amplified,
but still mia.
Yeah,
I get that a lot.
They like,
yeah,
they get upset at you because.
Oh yeah.
Talk about silicon cock.
Too much hate douche bag.
I think about that.
All right.
I'm going to talk about whatever I want
to.
You talk about whatever you want to.
Don't worry about me.
lee.
Funny idea that there's something bad
about swear words.
It's so juvenile.
All words are artificial.
We make words to two so we can relay
what we're seeing and there's all sorts
of adjectives that are just as
ridiculous.
Like the idea that freakin is okay.
Like creek clean people say freaking
this freaking guy and they feel clean
and free of any wrongdoing,
but if you say fucking with the same
story like seminar that you screwing up,
that's so weird.
Right?
And if you look in like music,
movies,
everything else is so dirty now and now
like there's very little clean comedy
left though.
That's not,
that's not very common anymore.
There's the christian base as funny
people of faith was a tour that was
going on through the,
uh,
through the improv chains and it was at
the,
uh,
Arizona improv comedy based on the bible
and she does like arenas.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
I've seen guys do that too.
There was a guy named brad stein who was
really not very funny in my opinion,
back in the day.
He just was real hacky and just gross.
Well,
he became this like really right wing
christian comic and just started
crushing and like selling out giant
places and some books and I got a cd.
I bought it at a used record store just
because I was curious.
It was one of the strangest cds I've
ever heard in my life.
Completely devoid of like humor,
but just like weird cheerleading,
right wing god fearing cheerleading.
Like
it was so bizarre.
But I always laugh at those people
because eventually they be,
they're human and it catches up with
them while they start banging chicks and
ted haggard.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who's that?
who's that one priest right now that's
from a.
He's in houston.
He talked like this and he's like,
he plays like a stadium is churches like
a stadium?
They have a lot of those in Texas.
Bands believe in everybody and it's
like,
dude,
I'm like,
I look in his eyes.
I go,
that guy seen darkness.
He's selling something,
but there are some darkness lurking,
bro.
Ted haggard pulled it off for a long
time before he got busted.
Who knows how many guys are out there
that are going to get caught that george
records.
God,
that was the head of the christian ride.
He was a right almost.
Yep.
Joel olsteen dude,
that guy and I hear he's a nice guy,
but through there's darkness lurking,
bro.
My tivo records that guy every week and
have no idea why.
I just started recording it,
so I'll sit in bed and just watch it
sometimes just out of curiosity and
that's it shits creepy.
The lord.
Your life son need to load in your life
and his wife's got that big hair and big
makeup.
Crazy shit,
man.
It's so interesting because they got
that crazy politics,
but they're the funnest people.
The party with the best
drinking,
drinking in dallas,
drinking in austin.
True.
You can find some great drink and
partners in austin and have some fucking
fun.
Yeah,
man.
let that pot's illegal.
Man.
You get fucking thrown in jail for pot
there.
It's so stupid.
It's a.
They got to fix that.
It's Texas.
Texas should be sucking the fucking
corporate dick of America like that.
Texas is supposed to be the only place
that can like.
Isn't this supposed to be legally able
to secede from the union because it's a
republic of taxes or something crazy
like really religious and and big
business go hand in hand.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
I do know,
but it's so funny that people,
reagan,
reagan in the eighties
did everything wholesome to religion and
you know the whole right wing religion,
christian,
christian movement really got involved
in politics during the reagan era.
they realized they could tap into those
dummies and start selling them shit.
Selling them god,
god,
guns and country.
And I just pushed it and ran with it.
It's so amazing.
It's amazing.
It's amazing because they are the people
that give the fuck the least about the
common man.
You know corporations over the last
terminators.
did they really are?
Man.
They have.
They do not care.
My attempt trIply.
This is an epic
long show.
This is the longest show we've ever done
here.
We do.
We did.
Do we know what?
We were ready to wrap it up too,
but we got reinvigorated talking about
standup comedy and the comedy store and
that's one of the things I love about
you,
sam,
tripoli,
you,
you're a real fierce fucking comedian.
You're the real deal.
You're out there really doing it under
patrick swayze.
There's a lot of dudes who,
you know,
they could be stand up comedians or
they'd be fucking insurance salesmen or
whatever.
You're a fucking standup comic.
You know,
you're the real deal.
thanks man.
It's always an honor.
The crops.
My brother hang out with you too,
man.
You too.
My favorite people and always loved
going on the road with you,
man.
Yeah,
well gonna,
tear it up again.
July second.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm sam and I will be at the,
uh,
house of blues and mandalay bay is the
night before the ufc and uh,
we're going to have fucking partied on
end tomorrow night.
Sam triply has his show at the melrose
improv in hollywood,
8:00
PM,
the naughty show.
It's a fucking pisser I've seen it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I loved it.
You'll love it.
Thank you for tuning in.
We will see you guys next week.
Most likely tuesday,
same bat time,
same bat channel.
Thank you again.
As always,
we appreciate you.
This show just keeps growing every week
and we're enjoying the shit out of doing
it and I'm just a very happy that
everybody's enjoying it and I keep
meeting people on the road that love it
and it means a lot to me and I'm glad
you love it and we're not going to stop.
So thank you guys.
Take care.
Dr.
Seuss.